SESSION FOR TWENTY TWENTY- WE
HAVE FOUR ITEMS ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY- ONE AND NOTIFY YOU THAT
ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHT ZERO ONE
ONE BY SIMILAR LACKEY IS ON
CONSENT- SO WE'LL BE HEARING-
THREE ITEMS- AND- TO SERVE
REMINDER OF OUR COMMITTEE
RULES- BASICALLY- WE WILL TAKE.
THE INITIAL TESTIMONY FROM- THE
AUTHOR AND THEN WE WILL
FOLLOWED BY WITNESSES FIRST IN
SUPPORT- WE USUALLY HAVE A SIX
MINUTE TOTAL LIMIT SO IF YOU
HAVE TO WITNESSES THAT'S THREE
MINUTES APIECE TO BE THREE
WITNESSES IT'S TWO MINUTES
THESE. AND WE ASK THAT. YOU DO
NOT HAVE TO USE ENTIRE SIX
MINUTES IF YOU DON'T WISH TO
AND THEN WE WILL THAT TAKE THE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY AND SAME
RULES APPLY. SO WITH THAT- WE
ARE- WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE HAD AND THEN ONCE WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL THEN-
FEEL THE SOUTHEAST QUORUM. SO
WITH THAT I SEE CENTER MORE
LIGHT HERE- SO EVEN THOUGH- SO
WHAT WHAT'S GO AHEAD WITH ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB SIX FORTY WELCOME
CENTER MORE LACK. AND FORTY
HEARING TESTIMONY ON YOUR BILL
THANK YOU. WHO IS TO BE A TO
YOUR BILL- I HAVE- BEEN. DOING
A LOT OF RESEARCH. ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL- THE IDEAS AND
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PROPOSE.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
ADDITIONAL TIME- WE HAVE MADE A
MODIFICATION AND THAT IS TO
MAKE IT OPTIONAL FOR COUNTIES
THAT WISH TO- MODIFY THEIR
DEFINITION. OF GRAVELY
DISABLED. SO WE DO WE DID FIND
OUT THAT THERE ARE SOME. ERRORS
OR A MAYBE SOME MINOR
MODIFICATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
MADE- IN THE BILL AND SO WILL
ACCEPT THAT AS AN AMENDMENT IF
NEEDED. I THINK THAT WAS IN
YOUR STAFF REPORT. JUST TO
CLEAR THE TICKET WILL CLARIFY I
DON'T I WAS NOT AWARE WE HAVE
IF THERE IS SOMETHING WE WILL
AGREE TO MODIFY. OKAY SO YEAH
WE WANT MINOR LIKE THEY DIVERSE
A POLICY COMMENT BUT THERE WAS
WORDS. AND. WE CAN AND. IN LATE
ENOUGH AS AN ERROR OKAY JUSTIN
OKAY YEAH THERE IS WE DON'T
HAVE A FORMAL AMENDMENTS
PROPOSE THAT I'M AWARE OF ALL
THE PARTS COMING DID POINT OUT
THERE WAS AN ERROR. SO THAT'S
WHY BILL OF SALE WE DIDN'T HAVE
A ANY SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED THAT'S WHY I WAS THE
MONEY SURE WE'RE CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SO.
THEN STRACK STRIKE THROUGH THE
COMMENT. OKAY. ASKING OKAY I
MEAN WE'RE WE'RE CERTAINLY
WILLING TO ACCEPT THAT BUT.
FIXED UP IF YOU DON'T MIND WILL
PAUSE FOR MOMENTS HERE THEY TO
CONSULT WITH STAFF
. SO ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW IT BABY MAYBE WE'VE
LET'S LET'S CONFER THEIR OKAY
SO. WILL TEMPORARILY- FOR A
BRIEF TIME RECESS TO CONFER
WITH THE AUTHOR
. OKAY WILL
RECONVENE HERE SO- THANK YOU
CENTER MORE LACK SITE SO IT TO
SO THERE IS ACTUALLY SO JUST BE
SURE WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE-
THERE WAS THERE'S AN ATTEMPTBY
USED TO CORRECT A THIRD I WAS
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS BUT
WE AT LEAST. TO ME DIDN'T
SPECIFICALLY MENTION A SPECIFIC
AMENDMENT SO WHEN USE SITES
WILL BE SURE WORK AND TELL ME
IF I GOT IT WRONG- THAT WHAT
YOU'RE BASICALLY SUPPRESSING IS
THAT YOU INTEND TO. TAKE
MINUTES TO FIX THE PROBLEM
IDENTIFIED ALICE'S REGARDING- A
THAT THE THAT THE AIR AND THEN
FIND IN ALICE'S CORRECT ALL
RIGHT OKAY PLEASE RISEN THANK
YOU I JUST WANNA BE SURE WE'RE
ALL IN THE SAME PLACE THANK
YOU. AND APPRECIATE YOUR.
VERIFYING THAT- RICHARD
OBVIOUSLY THE- PREEMINENT ISSUE
THAT THE VOTERS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT RIGHT NOW IS
HOMELESSNESS. AND THE GOVERNOR
JUST CAME OUT THIS MORNING WITH
AN INCREDIBLE- PLAN THAT- I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF- WITH A LOT OF-
COMPONENTS- BUT WE'RE WE'RE ALL
IN OUR DISTRICT STRUGGLING WITH
THIS. THIS CRISIS. AND WE
SPENT. THE SLASHER LOOKING AT
THE LATERAN PATRICK SHORT ACT
WHICH WAS A DISCUSSION WE HAD
WHEN I WAS HERE LAST YEAR ON.
HOW IT IS DOING THESE LAST
FIFTY YEARS IN THE LETTERMAN
PETROUS SHORT ACT SAID. THAT
INSTITUTIONS WERE FOR MENTALLY
ILL PEOPLE WORK IN YOU MAIN AND
WE SHOULD CLOSE THEM. AND SO WE
CLOSE THEM AND ALL. PEOPLE WENT
OUT IN THE STREETS AND THEN
THEY WENT INTO THE JAIL SO NOW
OUR JAILS AT LEAST AN ORANGE
COUNTY. MY LARGEST INST A
MENTAL HEALTH INSTITUTION IS MY
COUNTY JAIL IN DOWNTOWN SANTA
ANA. BUT WE'VE LOOKED REALLY
CLOSELY AT THIS ACTON- WE
SHOULD HAVE A DOCUMENT OUT SOON
ON WHAT WE'VE FOUND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT. ARE NOT A NOT IT HAS
BEEN REQUESTED THROUGH J. LACK
HAVE WITH THE STATE AUDITOR WE
SHOULD PROBABLY BE GETTING THE
RESULTS OF- ELAINE HOUSE WORK
IN APRIL. BUT WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT WHAT KIND OF
SOLUTIONS CAN WE PROVIDE-
BECAUSE MY CONSTITUENTS ARE
REAL CONCERNED ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS AND I KNOW WHAT
YOURS ARE TOO. AND WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE MENTAL HEALTH
SPACE. AND WITH THAT- WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT WHAT IS THE
BEST DEFINITION FOR GRAVELY
DISABLED WE'VE LOOKED AT OTHER
STATES AND MAYBE JUST FOR
EXAMPLE YOU HAVE IT IN YOUR-
STAFF REPORT THAT NEVADA SAYS
CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER TO
SELF. AND WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO WE HELP. SEVERELY
MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE THAT ARE ON
THE STREETS. SO THEY'RE NOT NOT
ONLY A DANGER TO THEMSELVES BUT
A DANGER TO OTHERS BECAUSE-
WE'RE HAVING INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE BEING CONCERNED ABOUT WHO
THEY BUMP INTO AND GROCERY
STORE PARKING LOT SIR. WE I
JUST HAD A STACK STATE EMPLOYER
FIND OUT JUST- YESTERDAY. I WAS
ATTACKED AT A LOCAL STARBUCKS
BY A HOMELESS PERSON WHO MAY
HAVE HAD. SOME MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES. SO WITH THAT- WE'RE
WE'RE- KIND OF THE KIND OF COME
TO THE CONCLUSION AS A LAY
PERSON NOT AS A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL BUT- AT REALIZING
THAT MAYBE A FIFTY ONE FIFTY.
SEVENTY TWO HOUR HOLD ISN'T
GOING TO CUT IT FOR A LOT OF.
INDIVIDUALS SO WITH THAT IF
SOME COUNTIES HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN
PROVIDE- FOR THE SERVICES OF
INDIVIDUALS OF THIS NATURE THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO OPT IN. WE
DID IT WAS SAN FRANCISCO
RECENTLY WITH SB ONE OH FOUR
FIVE WOULDN'T TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND- SB FORTY JUST LAST YEAR
WITH THE PILOT FOR NOT ONLY SAN
FRANCISCO BUT LA AND SAN DIEGO.
SO WHY NOT IF THERE ARE OTHER
COUNTIES THAT ARE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE. WE SHOULD. GIVE
THEM THE OPTION ORANGE COUNTY
HAS BEEN WORKING VERY
DILIGENTLY. ON ESTABLISHING A
NETWORK TO HELP MENTALLY ILL
PEOPLE WE JUST HAD DURRELL
STEINBERG AND DOCTOR TOM
INSULT. IN OUR COUNTY TO
DEDICATE A BUILDING IN MY
DISTRICT WHICH IS SIXTY
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET TO HELP
THOSE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS SO.
IF THEY ARE WILLING TO MODIFY
THE DEFINITION WE SHOULD GIVE
THEM THAT OPPORTUNITY- BECAUSE
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING I THINK%
THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE-
SOLUTION THE DILEMMA- HAS BEEN
IN THE- OF THE- OPPOSITION IN
THE MAIN OF OPPOSITION MY
CONCERN IS BEEN. THE LACK OF
FACILITIES SO THE LETTERMAN
PATCHER SHORT ACT SAID WE
SHOULD CLOSE THE MENTAL HEALTH
INSTITUTIONS MOVE THEM INTO
COMMUNITY. FACILITIES BUT-
FIFTY YEARS LATER WE DON'T HAVE
COMMUNITY FACILITIES WHAT WE DO
HAVE NO PLACE LIKE HOME WHICH
WE APPROVED. LAST YEAR WITH
PROPOSITION. TWO AND SO WE ARE
HOPEFULLY STARTING TO BUILD
SOME- FACILITIES IN STRUCTURES
AND EVEN TODAY'S- PRESS RELEASE
BY THE GOVERNOR SAID LET'S PUT
ANOTHER SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION INTO. START BILLING AND
PROVIDING A PLACER PAYING FOR
RENT WE SHOULD ALSO BE WORKING
ON THE SPACE OF HOW DO WE
PROVIDE MORE INSURANCE
REIMBURSEMENTS- THE CARE HOMES
WERE ASKING FOR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE SET
MONDAYS LA TIMES ARE GETTING
SOMETHING. HOPEFULLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TODAY
IN AND IN HIS BUDGET- ON THE
TENTH. AND WE NEED TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO WITH I AM DE WAIVERS
TO TRY AND GET. MORE FUNDING
DOWN TO THOSE THAT ARE OUR
SYSTEM THESE INDIVIDUALS.
BECAUSE WE NEED TO PROVIDE SOME
KIND OF COMMUNITY FACILITIES
BUT WE NEED TO START THE
MOMENTUM COLLEAGUES. AND
ACHIEVE SOME SUCCESSES AND
COUNTIES WILLING TO STEP UP TO
THE CURRENT- SITUATION INSTEAD
OF JUST LETTING PEOPLE DIE ON
OUR STREETS LA COUNTY IS LOSING
THREE PEOPLE A DAY ON AVERAGE.
THAT ARE HOMELESS ON THE
STREETS. SO I BRING THIS OUT OF
A SOME KIND OF EXPERIENCE
MISTER CHAIR. WHEN WE HAD A
SCHIZOPHRENIC HOMELESS PERSON-
KILLED IN FULLERTON BY THE NAME
OF KELLY THOMAS. DOCTORS AND
PARENTS CAME TO ME AND SAID WE
SHOULD HAVE ADOPTED LORES LAW
SO I WORKED WITH SENATOR
STEINBERG AND WE DID SB FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE IN TWENTY THIRTEEN.
GOT ME UP HERE A LOT AND HAD A
LOT OF FUN WORKING ON IT- BUT
IT WAS APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE SIGNED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN AND IT PROVIDED A LITTLE
BIT OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT FUNDING- PROP SIXTY THREE
TO FUND FOR LORDS LOS ORANGE
COUNTY BECAME THE SECOND COUNTY
AFTER NEVADA COUNTY. AND NOW WE
HAD SEVENTEEN COUNTIES THAT
HAVE FOLLOWED SUIT. JUST HAD A
RECENT STUDY THAT SAID THAT
THAT'S ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT PROGRAM IS NOT ONLY
WORKING WELL IN THOSE NINETEEN
COUNTIES. BUT WHY AREN'T THE
OTHER. THIRTY NINE COUNTIES
STEPPING UP AND DOING THE SAME
THING SO WE HAVE SOME SUCCESS.
SO THAT'S WHY I'M IN THIS SPACE
MISTER CHAIR- BECAUSE I THINK
THIS SB SIX FORTY PROVIDES A
SIMILAR. STRATEGY WE WOULDN'T
LEAVE SOMEONE WITH ALZHEIMER'S
OUT ON THE STREET. BUT THIS
BILL SAYS. THAT IF YOU ARE
INCAPABLE OF MAKING INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT OR PROVIDING
FOR THE PERSON'S OWN BASIC
PERSONAL NEEDS FOR FOOD
CLOTHING OR SHELTER WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT SUPERVISION AND
ASSISTANCE FROM ANOTHER PERSON
WE SHOULD WE SHOULD BE HOUSING
YOU AND WE SHOULD BE DIAGNOSING
AND WE SHOULD BE PROVIDING THE
APPROPRIATE MEDICTION WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN NEW IN
THE LAST FIFTY YEARS OR WE CAN
GET YOU- GET THAT THAT PERSON
NORMALIZED IN BACK INTO THE
MAINSTREAM SOCIETY WE'VE GOT TO
GET THEM ON A PROGRAM. AND
SOMETIMES IT TAKES LONGER THAN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS SO IN A
TEMPORARY INVOLUNTARY HOLD IS
MORE BENEFICIAL THAN
INCARCERATION WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW SO I'VE
HAD A LOT OF FUN MISTER CHAIR
ON THIS BILL I'M NOT A DOCTOR
BUT I HAD FUN MEETING WITH
DOCTOR TOM INSEL WHO HAS A
WONDERFUL NATIONAL REPUTATION
SO WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE
HIM HERE AT THE STATE. AND WE
HAVE I HAD THE CHANCE TO MEET
WITH DOCTOR JONATHAN SHARING
WHOSE- THE MIDDLE HEALTH
DIRECTOR IN LA COUNTY AND JUST
VERY IMPRESSIVE- ALSO BEEN
WORKING WITH THAT DR DREW
PINSKY WAS ALSO PSYCHIATRIST
WHO'S BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
BUT I'M TREATED SCHIZOPHRENIA
MAKES THE CONDITION MORE
DETRIMENTAL IF WE DON'T TREAT
THESE PEOPLE THEY ACTUALLY
DEGRADING GET WORSE SO THE
SOONER THE BETTER AND THEREFORE
I AM STRONGLY ENCOURAGING AN
AYE VOTE ON SENATE BILL SIX
FORTY TO. ASSIST THOSE THAT. WE
NEED TO HELP ON OUR STREETS
WHICH IS. CRITICAL AT THIS TIME
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH WITNESSES
I DO SEE THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM
SO I'M GOING TO ASK THAT THE
SICK RECALL THE ROLE TO
SUBSEQUENT. CAM PAN HERE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE GROVE.
GROVE HERE HER TADO. ATTARDO
HERE LEYVA. LEYVA HERE MITCHELL
MITCHELL HERE MINING RUBIO. WE
HAVE A QUORUM OKAY THANK YOU SO
WITNESSES REPORT WELCOME MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH PANAY ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND MY FAMILY
AND MY FRIENDS. FIVE I THE MY
MOM WAS SCHIZOPHRENIC FOR FIFTY
NINE YEARS- WAS ON THE ON AND
OFF THE STREETS. FIVE AND THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE IN PLACE ISN'T
WORKING. I COULD TELL YOU A
VARIETY OF STORIES BUT- A GREAT
STORY IS IN THE CHRONICLE ON
SATURDAY THIS GENTLEMAN. HAVING
REAL PROBLEMS OUR SYSTEM IS
IGNORING THEM HE'S ON THE
STREETS HIS SISTERS HAVE TRIED
TO HELP AND THEY'VE GOTTEN NO
WHERE. WITH THE CENTERS TRYING
TO DO IS PROVIDE COUNTIES WITH
THE FLEXIBILITY TO SEE THESE
PEOPLE THAT WE WALK BY EVERYDAY
ON THE STREETS. THE SACRAMENTO
HAS TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN ITS FINE TODAY. BUT THE
COUNTY DOESN'T HAVE THE
JURISDICTION TO ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING- THAT'S THE PROBLEM-
SO I WOULD URGE YOU TO HELP
THIS ALONG RIGHT NOW. I SAW
THAT THE NEXT TIME WE WALK BY
ONE OF THESE PEOPLE ON THE
STREET WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO CALL
SOMEBODY SOMEBODY BESIDES THE
POLICE AND GET THEM SOME DIRE
NEEDED HELP- SO MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'VE SPOKEN TO YOU ABOUT THIS
BEFORE- THIS FIRST TIME I'VE
SPOKEN PUBLICLY HI AND SO IT'S
A LITTLE HARD FOR ME AFTER
FIFTY NINE YEARS OF MY MOM
SUFFERING- IN AND OUT OF STATE
HOSPITALS. I'M NOT A BIG
ADVOCATE OF A MAN STATE
HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN SEEN THEM
WHEN I WAS FIVE AND TEN ELEVEN
AND TWELVE AND FIFTEEN GOING TO
VISIT MY MOM. BUT THERE IS A
POINT IN TIME WHERE WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT FOLKS WHO
NEED OUR HELP AND I'LL LEAVE
YOU WITH THIS- IT JUST A BRIEF
FROM SENATOR NICK PETROUS IS
ORAL BIOGRAPHY. AND IT'S JUST A
SMALL PIECE AND I COULD HAVE A
COPY OF THIS IS THAT IT'S A
FOUR HUNDRED PAGE BY OUR ORAL
OR A BIOGRAPHY BUT- CENTER
PICTURES WHO I KNEW. IN THE LPS.
BASICALLY SAID- UPON REFLECTION
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE SO IS
LAW WENT INTO EFFECT IN SIXTY
SEVEN HE AND LANCE FOR MEN AND
SHORT AND THIS IS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE HE SAID WELL I TELL
YOU WHAT I WOULD SAY IF SOMEONE
LEFT ME ON THE STREET BASICALLY
IS WHAT HE'S SAYING I'D SAY
DAMMIT DON'T I HAVE A RIGHT TO
TREATMENT. IF I HAD BROKEN MY
LEG OR HAD A HEART ATTACK YOU'D
BE SWARMING ALL OVER THE PLACE
TO HELP ME BY DOCTORS NURSES
THIS WAY AND THAT WAY SO I JUST
LEAVE YOU WITH THAT I'LL MAKE A
COPY OF THIS THE TO ONLY ABOUT
THIRTY PAGES IS PRETTY
INTERESTING READING TO SEE WHO
THE PLAYERS WERE ON BOTH SIDES
WHO WAS AGAINST IT WHO WAS FOR
IT- THEY HAD TOTAL OPPOSITION-
WELL AS THEY ARE WORKING THEIR
WAY THROUGH IT BUT I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING FOR ALL OF YOU TO
READ THIS. PIECE OF HISTORY
FROM SENATOR PATRIS IT WAS THE
FACT THIS GUY HE WAS THE
LIBERAL LAND TURMAN WAS THE
LIBERTARIAN AND SHORT WAS OF BY
THE SENATOR WHO JUST WANTED
SOME COMMUNITY FACILITIES HE
THOUGHT THAT WAS THE BEST THING
THAT COULD POSSIBLY HAPPEN SO I
AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS BUT I REALLY APPLAUD
THE SENDER'S EFFORT YOUR
EFFORTS MISTER CHAIRMAN YOUR
ALL YOUR EFFORTS BUT NOW'S THE
TIME TO START MOVING THIS
PROGRAM ALONG GIVE THE COUNTIES
THE FLEXIBILITY. WITH THIS TYPE
OF LANGUAGE THEN PUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS INSTEAD OF THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION THAT GOT TO
LEAD FROM THE BUDGET LASHER PUT
A HUNDRED MILLION TO THE
COUNTIES WHO WERE WILLING TO GO
OUT AND TRY TO DO SOMETHING
WITH THESE FOLKS AND HELP THESE
FOLKS WITH TREATMENT AND THEN
HELP THOSE COUNTIES WHO ARE
HELPING WITH CITIES WORKING
TOGETHER AND GIVE THEM PRIORITY
WHEN THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO
WORKS WITH THE COUNTY OF
SACRAMENTO THEY GET PRIORITY
FOR THESE FUNDS TO HOUSE THESE
PEOPLE. AND IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE A HOME WHERE KILEY THEN.
THAT IS MY MOM COULD DO. DO A
AT. WE NEED TO PUT. KING IS
THERE STOP BURKE THE MAN IN
THAT SO I'D OR CHIU BEST OF
THIS LONG FOR TODAY AND THEN
KEEP WORKING ON ALL OF THESE
THINGS BY AND GIVE US ALL HOPE
WHEN WE WALK WHEN I DOMY FIVE
MY WALK EVERY MORNING GIVE US
HOPE THAT I CAN CALL SOMEBODY
SOMEBODY BUT THE CHIEF OF
POLICE AND SAY HEY COME AND
HELP THIS WOMAN. SO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT BACK
MICROPHONE. NAME ORGANIZATION
AND SIMPLY POSITION SUPPORT
AFTERNOON THE MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LARRY MORSE BEHALF
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
MERION BERNARD AND I SPEAK AS A
LAWYER VERY FAMILIAR WAS
SUPERIOR COMPLETE COMMITMENT
LAWS IN OTHER STATES AND AS THE
MOTHER OF A SEVERELY MENTALLY
ILL YOUNG ADULT ON BEHALF OF
MANY OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS WE
BELIEVE THAT SB SIX FORTY
SHOULD BE ADOPTED STATEWIDE AS
SHOULD LAURA'S LAW. BUT BUT- SO
WILL AT THE BACK MICROPHONE ITS
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITIONS
SO WE HEAR TESTIMONY AT THE-
TABLE. ALL RIGHT WELL. IT NEEDS
TO BE AMENDED UP BECAUSE IT
FORCES PERRANCE TO THROW THEIR
CHILDREN ON THE STREETS IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO BE CONSIDERED
GRAVELY DISABLED IT HAS
HAPPENED TO ME PERSONALLY IT IS
HAPPENED TO MANY OTHER PARENTS.
THIS IS A PROBLEM I KNOW HOW TO
FIX IT. I HAVE THE LANGUAGE. I
WILL BE HERE AND I WILL BE
OUTSIDE THIS CONFERENCE ROOM
WHEN THIS HEARING ENDS. SO THAT
I CAN TALK TO PEOPLE ABOUT THAT
AND I WILL ALSO EMAIL YOU DR
OKAY AND ACTUALLY IF YOU HAVE
SOME A LANGUAGE OR SOME HAS
MADE YOU WANT TO. SHARE WITH
THE COMMITTEE PLEASE- PRESENTED
THE SERGEANTS AND WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THAT. THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH. PERSECUTE US HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA IN SUPPORT. OKAY THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT I SEE NO THE
WITNESSES A SUPPORT WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE COME UP
TO THE TABLE. SHOULD GO BACK.
KAY AND ASSUME YOU'VE
COORDINATED YOUR TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR- MEMBERS KERR
CHILD DISABILITYRIGHTS
CALIFORNIA- UNFORTUNATELY WE-
CONTINUE TO HAVE AN OPPOSE
POSITION TO THIS BILL- RULE THE
BILL WAS ESSENTIALLY THE BILL
THAT WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO-
DISCUSS AND DEBATE- LAST YEAR
AND- AS WE RACED AT THAT TIME A
NUMBER OF OUR CONCERNS
PARTICULARLY- FIRST OF ALL THIS
DEFINITION ITSELF AN ENTIRELY
NEW DEFINITION THAT WE WOULD
TRY TO JACK THE POND- R. LPS
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA WHICH WE
WOULD SUGGEST YOU KNOW SUCH
TERMS IS MAKING AND FOR IN
CAPABLE OF MAKING INFORMED
DECISIONS AND WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT SUPERVISION ARE ALL
UNDEFINED- TERMS THROUGH
THROUGHOUT THE STATUTE THAT. WE
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THAT WOULD
REALLY THROW INTO DISARRAY ARE
LPS SYSTEM THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- IT ALSO PROVIDES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THE
HISTORY OF TREATMENT- WHICH
ALWAYS IS A MATTER OF CONCERN-
IN LOOKING AT- WHAT- MAY HAVE
BEEN A PERSON- WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES IN THE PAST BEING
USED TO- TO ACTUALLY-
INVOLUNTARILY- CONFINE THEM AT
THE PRESENT TO- TIME- SO IT I
THINK OUR MAJOR CONCERN RIGHT
NOW IS A PARTICULARLY AS WE'RE
HAVING I THINK SOMEWHERE THE
CONVERSATIONS IS A SENATOR
MENTIONED AS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED NELSON- WILL WHAT
APPEARS TO BE SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES TO START LOOKING AT-
BOTH HOUSING. AND SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT'S BEEN OUR
POSITION ALL ALONG ON THIS IS
LET'S PUT THE NOT PUT THE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE LET'S FOCUS ON
MAKING SURE WE GOT SERVICES IN
PLACE- FOR- FOR INDIVIDUALS-
BEFORE DOING ANY TINKERING
WITH- THE STATUTORY-
DEFINITION. I WILL JUST ONE
YEAH BECAUSE THIS VERSION OF
THE BILL NOW INCLUDES THIS
OPTION- FOR COUNTY STOPPED IN
AND OUT IN THAT WOULD PUT US IN
AN EXTRAORDINARILY- DIFFERENT
POSITION THAN WE HAVE BEEN
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE COURSE OF
LPS WHERE. WE'VE BEEN STRIVING
TO UNIFORMITY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- IN APPLICATION OF LPS-
YOU WOULD HAVE COUNTIES- RIGHT
NEXT TO EACH OTHER POTENTIALLY-
EMPLOYING DIFFERENT STANDARDS
FOR- DETERMINING WHETHER A
PERSON SHOULD BE INVOLUNTARILY
HELD AND AGAIN THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS ALL ABOUT IS THE CIVIL
RIGHTS WE THINK. LPS AS HAS
BEEN FOR THE DECADES THAT WE'VE
HAD IT- REMARKABLY SUCCESSFUL
IN CONTINUING ON THE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE CIVIL RIGHTS F
INDIVIDUALS AND THE NEED TO
PROTECT THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND-
OTHERS. AND SO AGAIN WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE CONVERSATION
SHOULD HAPPEN IN THE CONTEXT OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE AS OPPOSED
TO TRYING TO SWEEP MORE PEOPLE
INTO A SYSTEM THAT WE KNOW IS
AT CURRENT TIME ILL EQUIPPED TO
HANDLE THEM SO WE WOULD URGE
AND A LOT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- TIRE IN
THE WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION-
REGRETFULLY WE ARE OPPOSED TO
SB SIX FORTY- THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE ADDITIONAL CONFUSION ON
FOR WHO IS APPROPRIATE FOR
CONSERVATORSHIP. I'MA CREATES
DISPARITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
WHO IS- ELIGIBLE FOR
CONSERVATORSHIP AND THEN IT
PROVIDES NO ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS- FOUR OR PROVIDERS
TO ADEQUATELY TREAT AN EXPANDED
POPULATION- A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF COUNTIES TODAY DO YOU
PLACE INDIVIDUALS- OUTSIDEOF
THEIR COUNTY INTO- LOCKED I AM
DIS AND BARDING CARES BASED ON
THEIR TREATMENT NEEDS. AND SO
YOU MIGHT HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE A COUNTY- THAT HAS OPTED
INTO THIS EXPANDED DEFINITION
WOULD PLACE AN INDIVIDUAL INTO
A COUNTY THAT HAS NOT OPTED IN-
AND SO YOU MIGHT HAVE SOMEONE
WALKING ON THE STREET I'M
STREETS WHO COULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS EXPANDED. UNDER THE
EXPANDED DEFINITION WHILE
SOMEONE ELSE IS ALREADY BEING
TREATED SO WE SEE THIS SIDE
SCREENING DISPARITIES IN
CONFUSION OF WHO WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR CONSERVATORSHIP
ACROSS THE STATE- ADDITIONALLY
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE DID APPROVE AN AUDIT
OF THE LPS ACT BACK IN JUNE OF
LAST YEAR. BUT SET TO BE
RELEASED IN APRIL OF THIS YEAR
AND RELUCTANT TO SUPPORT ANY
CHANGES THE LPS ACT UNTIL WE
SEE ANY- THE FINDINGS FROM THE
AUDIT. AND HAVE TIME TO REVIEW
AND ASSESS THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR- CONSERVATORSHIP
PROGRAMS ARE CURRENTLY IS
SERIOUSLY UNDERSTAFFED AND
UNDERFUNDED TODAY ANDIN A
STUDY BY THE PUBLIC GUARDIANS
ASSOCIATION. THEY'RE CURRENTLY
UNDERSTAFFED BY ABOUT 20%
ACROSS THE STATE AND THIS BILL
DOES NOT PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR AN EXPANDED
POPULATION- WE ALSO VIEW THAT.
THE COURTS ARE THE ONES THAT
MAKE THE ULTIMATE DECISION OF
WHO IS PLACED ON A
CONSERVATORSHIP AND THIS DOES
NOT PROVIDE ANY CLEAR GUIDANCE
TO THE COURTS. OF WHO IS THE
APPROPRIATE FOR CONSERVATORSHIP
AND WE DO SEE ACROSS THE STATE
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES IN WHO IS
CONCERNED- BY THE COURTS-
DECISIONS. SAU AND THERE'S BE
EXISTING NON. THAT ALSO DOES
NOT PROVIDE CLARIFICATION TO ON
THE COURTS AROUND A HOW MUCH
TREATMENT HISTORY CAN BE
ICLUDED THERE IS AN EXISTING
PROVISION OF THE LAW THAT DOES
ALLOW- HISTORY IT WITH AND THE
COURT DECISIONS I'M IN A
CONSERVATORSHIP CASE. BUT
THERE'S NOT GUIDANCE ABOUT HOW
MUCH HISTORY CAN BE INCLUDED
AND WE DO SEE I'VE OUT IT'S AN
ISSUE BUT THIS BILL IS NOT
SEEKING TO STOP THAT WITHIN.
THE EXISTING LAW SO AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE FORTUNATE
WE OPPOSED TO SB SIX FORTY
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION NAME
AND ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
AFTERNOON CHEN FLOOR ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
GETTING UPDATED LETTER IN BUT
WE REMAIN IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ALEX
HAWTHORN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN A
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION-
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS AROUND
THE PRACTICAL- IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE BILL AND OUR ABILITY TO
TREAT PATIENTS WHICH IS OUR
PRIORITY. IF THE BILL IS FOR
TODAY WERE COMMITTED TO KEEP
KEEP DOING THAT DIALOGUE WITH
SENATOR WE HAVE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE LETTER.
OKAY. MY NAME'S ALLISON MONROE
I'M FROM OAKLAND. I AM IN. I
EIGHT. AM AGAINST THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS THAT SEEM TO WATER
DOWN MISTER MORLOCKS BILL I
KNOW MR MORLOCK UNDERSTANDS OUR
PROBLEMS WE'RE PARENTS. OF THE
SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL I
REPRESENT FAST ME AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY WHICH IS. FAMILY MEMBERS
ADVOCATING FOR THE SERIOUSLY
MENTALLY ILL. I HAVE A DAUGHTER
WHO IS CONSERVED RIGHT NOW. BUT
I DON'T KNOW THAT SHE WON'T END
UP HOMELESS OR IN JAIL LIKE.
THE GREAT MAJORITY OF THE
STATE'S TEN THOUSAND SICKEST.
AND THE WAY TO DECIDE WHO NEEDS
TO BE CONSERVED IS WHAT IS BEST
FOR THEM TO KEEP THEM ALIVE AND
HEALTHY. MA'AM THE MAN OF MY
SHIRT HE LIVES IN THEM
BARKERVILLE CAMP OF THE- YEAR
YEAH I SEEN YOUR POST RIGHT.
I'M SORRY I'M NOT FAMILIAR
ENOUGH ITH YOUR PROCESS SO I
WANT WHATEVER MISTER MOORE Là
WANTS TO BE DONE WITHOUT THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS I SAW OKAY AS
I KNOW HIS HEART IS IN THE
RIGHT PLACE. YOU HAVE TO KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON. THESE TEN
THOUSAND ARE NOT GOING TO
TESTIFY HERE THEY'RE LOCKED UP
THERE IN JAIL THERE HOMELESS
THEY DON'T KNOW THEY'RE ILL FOR
THE MOST PART. SO THE PARENTS
HAVE TO COME IN REPRESENTED AN
ICY TO KEEP THEM ALIVE CONSERVE
THEM IF THEY NEED MEDICAL HELP
CONSERVE THEM IF THEY DON'T
KNOW THEY'RE SICK CONSERVE
THEM. IFTHEY'RE IN DANGER
THINGS ARE OF THEM. THANKS
THANK YOU. BACK MICROPHONE
AGAIN ITS NAME ORGANIZATION I
THINK. AND ALSO IF YOU HAVE
MATERIAL YOU WISH TO PRESENT-
YOU CAN. PRESENT TO GIVE THAT
TO THE SERGEANTS AND WITHOUT
GET TO THE COMMITTEE SELF. YOU
CAN EMAIL IT TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AS WELL WE CAN FIGURE
RANGE THAT SO THANK YOU FOR
COMING TESTIFIED. THE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES- SEEING NONE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY GROVE. THANK
YOU YOU KNOW AS READING AN
ARTICLE IN WE FACE HOMELESSNESS
IN EVERY COUNTY AND CITY THAT
IS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS A MATTER OF FACT- WE
INVESTED ALMOST BILLION DOLLARS
LAST CYCLE IN WERE UP 16%
HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER STATE IN
THE NATION. M. ON THE STREETS
OF LOS ANGELES IN TWO IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE PEOPLE DIED THERE
WERE HOMELESS AVERAGE OF THREE
A DAY IS WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS
HAPPENING NOW AT COMPARED TO
TWO HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT NEW
YORK AT IN THE FIRST SIX MONTHS
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE
DIED ON THE STREETS WE HAVE THE
STATISTICS OF WHO THEY ARE
BASED ON THE CORNERS OFFICE BY
RACE BY AGE- AND A LOT OF THE-
OTHER THAN THE OBVIOUS ONES
THAT ARE BROKEN DOWN BY NUMBER
BY. DEATH BY VIOLENCE. LIKE
THAT THAT THE LIST. THERE'S
EMOTIONAL DISORDERS THERE'S A
LOT OF. XIN IN THIS ARTICLE
THAT WAS I WAS READING THAT
TALKS ABOUT. MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND THEIR INABILITY TO
COPE ON THE STREET. AND WHEN I
SERVED IN THE ASSEMBLY ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES AND WE RUN BUDGET SUB
ONE AT WE LISTENED TO TESTIMONY
AFTER TESTIMONY AFTER TESTIMONY
OF THE CRUELTY THAT WENT ON IN
THE STATE INSTITUTIONS DEMI
SLIP AND SLIDE- ACTUAL MURDERS
PEOPLE BEING THROWN OUT OF
WINDOWS. JUST ALL KINDS OF
STUFF THAT WAS HAPPENING IN AND
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY IN THE
STATE SERVICES. AND SO THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION HAD-
THAT LEGISLATION THAT WENT
THROUGH AND ACTUALLY HAD
CLOSURE DATES ONE OF THOSE
FACILITIES IS IN YOUR DISTRICT-
NEVER IN A MILLION YEARS THAT I
THINK CLOSING DOWN THOSE ABUSE
RIDDLED INSTITUTIONS. WITH IN
DEPTH WITH- A MAJORITY OF THOSE
PEOPLE BEING ON THE STREET. NOT
BEING ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES NOT PEOPLE FEED
THEMSELVES. WE ENCOUNTER PEOPLE
EVEN IN BAKERSFIELD. AND I'M
NOT A DOCTOR. BUT OBVIOUSLY
WHEN YOU WALK UP WITH SOMEBODY
AND THEY'RE IN A WILL TURN THE
COMPLETELY ALMOST EMANCIPATED
THEY HAVEN'T EATEN IN DAYS YES
THERE. THEY CAN'T TALK AND THEY
HAVE NO AWARENESS OF WHO THEY
ARE WHAT THEY'RE DOING. AND
IT'S JUST CRUEL TO LEAVE THEM
OUT ON THE STREET. AND YOU
ENCOUNTER OTHER INDIVIDUALS ON
THE STREET THAT OBVIOUSLY ARE
TALKING TO PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
THERE- ENGAGING IN TRAFFIC. OF
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY CAN GET
RUN OVER BY A CAR STOPPING
TRAFFIC. THE YOU KNOW AND YOU
KNOW CARS ARE JUST DODGED HIM
AND THEY'RE OUT THERE TALKING
AND YELLING TO PEOPLE THAT
AREN'T THERE WILL. ON THE
STREETS. AND IT'S JUST SAD THAT
WE AS A SOCIETY ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN AND- YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT DEATH LIKE I SAID NINE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE PEOPLE
IN LOS ANGELES ALONE. AND IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN. SO
WHO TO AND TO ALL THE PARENTS
THE THOUSANDS OF PARENTS OUT
THERE THAT HAVE TO DEAL WITH
CHILDREN THAT ARE DISABLED
MENTALLY INCAPACITATED AND YOU
CAN'T. DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT YOU
JUST HAVE TO LET YOUR KID LIVE
ON THE STREET OR IN JAIL. I
THINK ALTERING LANGUAGE. ERR.
IN A DIFFERENT THE WITNESS THAT
WAS HER FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
YOU SAID YOU KNOW THERE'S
CURRENTLY COUNTIES ARE IN A
QUICK YOU KNOW ILL EQUIPPED TO
HANDLE THIS WELL COUNTIES AND
CITIES ARE ILL EQUIPPED TO
HANDLE THE HOMELESS ON THE
STREETS AND SO AND THERE HAS TO
BE SOLUTIONS WE CAN'T CONTINUE
TO HAVE HOMELESSNESS INCREASE
AND NOT DO ANYTHING FOR
SOLUTIONS WE CAN'T JUST THROW
MONEY AT IT WOULD YOU HOUSING
FIRST WHICH EVERYBODY THOUGHT
THAT WAS A GREAT IDEA BUT YOU
PUT PEOPLE IN HOUSING INITIALLY
DICK TO DRUGS AND THEY HAVE
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
THERE'S NO WRAPAROUND PROCESS.
AND SO YOU CREATING AND SAFE
ENVIRONMENT OTHER PEOPLE THAT
ARE TRYING TO GET HOUSING AND
SO THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
BOUNDARIES BUT- AND I AM ALL
ABOUT IT PERSON INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS AND THEN TO BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE WHAT IS THE BEST FOR
THEM BUT ALL OF THAT HAS TO
COME A CAPABILITY OF THEM.
MAKING CHOI S. OR THE. AND SO
AT. I THINK THE OFFERING THIS
BILL I THINK THE CHAIR FOR
WORKING WITH HIM OVER A TWO
YEAR PERIOD TO DISCUSS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT ARE COMING UP-
BUT JUST TO SAY THAT THE
COUNTIES ARE ILL EQUIPPED TO
DEAL WITH THIS THE CAN ISRAEL
EQUIPPED TO DEAL WITH THE
HOMELESS POPULATION IS GOING ON
SO THIS GIVING THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PICK UP THE
PHONE AND CALL SOMEONE EITHER
WE HAVE PEOPLE WE HAVE A WOMAN
THAT WAS ON THE STE THE OTHER
DAY AND I CALLED THE VICTIMS
THE WOMAN'S DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CENTER THAT MY COLLEAGUE IN. AN
IN THAT COUNTY AND THE KINGS
COUNTY AREA TOURED WITH ME AND
THEY CN TAKE HER BECAUSE SHE
HAD BEEN SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
SHE'D BEEN BRUTALIZED AND SHE
WAS OUT OF YOU KNOWN AT NOT
CAPABLE AND OBVIOUSLY AND LIKE
I SAID I'M NOT A DOCTOR BUT
IT'S IT WAS VERY EVIDENT THAT
THIS INDIVIDUAL WAS NOT CAPABLE
OF BEING ON THE STREET TAKING
CARE OF HERSELF BUT THEY CAN
TAKE HER BECAUSE SHE HAD BEEN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED. THEM SO
IT'S FRUSTRATING THAT THERE'S
NO WAY TO HELP THESE PEOPLE IN
OF CHANGING A SMALL BIT OF
LANGUAGE IN A SECTION OF CODE
WILL ALLOW PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
BE HELP SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE STUFF
THEY NEED INSTEAD OF JUST
LEAVING THE STREET TO DIE- SB
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN THE TWENTY
IN TWENTY TWENTY- I SUPPORT THE
BILL. CERTAINLY SIR. OKAY
CENTER TARA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO. IT SEEMS THAT THIS
BILL NEEDS A LITTLE BIT MORE
WORK- HOWEVER I A. IT YOU KNOW
I READ AN ARTICLE RECENTLY FROM
THAT AN OP ED FROM A MOTHER AND
MY DISTRICT ARE AND I KNOW THAT
THE HOMELESS ISSUE WAS BROUGHT
UP BUT I KIND OF I'M THINKING
OF THIS BILL IN A DIFFERENT-
WAY I'M THINKING AND I WANT TO
SHARE A COUPLE LINES THAT THE
THAT THE MOM SHARED ABOUT. HER
EXPERIENCE. SHE WROTE- HE SAT
ON THE TRAIN TRACK AND HE WAS
PRAYING WHEN HE DIED. AND IT
WAS THE HARDEST DAY OF MY LIFE.
THOSE ARE TEARS NO PARENT EVER
WANTS TO SHED. AND HEARTBREAK
NO MOTHER OR FATHER EVER WANTS
TO FEEL. HE WAS TWENTY FOUR
YEARS OLD AT THIS HAPPENED
ABOUT A HERE AND- FIVE MONTHS
AGO- HE BATTLED WITH
SCHIZOPHRENIA. AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE. AND HE HAD A HOME HE WAS
AN HOMELESS I THINK THAT- THAT
WE REALLY DISCARDED PINK AND
FOCUSED AND ON HELPING PEOPLE
PERIOD. AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY TO
KEEP THE CONVERSATION GOING-
BUT AS I MENTIONED EARLIER IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT NEEDS. SOME
WORK- BUT I'M DOING IT I'M
THINKING OF THE MOTHER AND THE
CHILD THAT SHE LOST BECAUSE NO
ONE DESERVES STIR TO LOSE THEIR
CHILD AND- WE NEED TO WORK ON
MAKING SURE THAT THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN EVER AGAIN. THANK YOU.
TURNS OUT. YOU IF YOU. NO THEY
GOT THERE I AM A WHILE YOU
UNDERSTAND. THE SPIRIT OF THIS
STATE I CERTAINLY DO I THINK
ALL OF US ARE DEALING WITH THIS
ISSUE COMING FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SING THE ISSUE EVERY DAY
TALKING ABOUT IT EVERY DAY AND
NOT SEE AND ALSO WITH GOOD
INTENTION- I. WOULD SAY I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL HAS A LOT
MORE WORK- AND SO I DO AGREE
WITH THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
THAT- WE HAVE AN AD AUDIT YOU
KNOW THAT STILL IS IN THE
WORKS- TO EVEN FIGURE OUT AND
THE DEFINITION OF THE LPS AND
HOW IT'S APPLIED IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND SO I THINK
THAT IN ITSELF. I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN UNDERSTANDING
WITH THAT DATA AND INFORMATION
LOOK LIKE FIRST BEFORE WE MOVED
TO HEAD. AND ALSO KNOWING THE
LA COUNTY HAS A HOUSING
CONSERVATORSHIP THROUGH SB
FORTY. THE PEOPLE DON'T EVEN
KNOW ABOUT IT AT THIS POINT WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT EVEN MEANS
AND SO IN WHEN YOU TALK TO LA
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH AS WELL
THEY'RE DIVIDED. US SOME FOLKS.
DIFFERENT THING AND SO I THINK
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF WORK TO DO
BUT I LIKE TO KNOW THAT THIS
CAN STILL REMAIN AND EVOLVING
BILLS AT THIS TIME I WON'T
SUPPORT THIS BUT I JUST WANTED
TO. ENSURE YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT
THANK YOU. THAT'S MITCHELL
THANK YOU SINCE MY COLLEAGUE
REFERENCE ME AND HER- MONEY I
WANTED TO PROVIDE A CLEAR FOR
CATION FROM MY PERSPECTIVE SUB
ONE WE WERE A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO TALKING ABOUT THE CLOSURE
OF DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND
THE CHALLENGE WITH THE FROM
SOMEONE FROM PEOPLE'S
PERSPECTIVE THE DELAY IN HAVING
A SCHEDULE. WAS TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE WHO WAS BEING
REMOVED FROM THE CENTERS WAS
PLACED IN A HOME AND SO WHILE
THERE'S BEEN A NUMBER OF
REASONS WHY WE HAVE HAD THIS
REALLY KIND OF SLOW BURN THIS
UPTICK IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER
OF HOMELESS IT'S NOT A RESULT
OF THE CLOSURE OF THOSE TO BE
SOME DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS THE
REASON THEY TOOK SO LONG FOR
THE CLOSURE WAS TO FIND AN
APPROPRIATE COMMUNITY SADDAM
PLACEMENT SO I JUST WANTED TO
PROVIDE THAT CLARIFICATION THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN SOME OF THE WORK
THAT TOOK PLACE- ON BEFORE YOU
GOT TO THE SENATE COLLEAGUE-
THAT THAT. DIDN'T WANT TO
CONFLATE THOSE TWO ISSUES DO WE
HAVE PEOPLE IN THE STREET WHO
SHOULDN'T BE WITHOUT QUESTION-
DID WE- AS A STATE AS THE
LEGISLATURE OF ADMINISTRATION
NOTDO WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE DONE
WHEN THE STATE MENTAL HEALTH
HOSPITALS WERE CLOSE FORTY
YEARS AGO ABSOLUTELY MUST WE DO
MORE IN TERMS OF BOARDING CARE
FACILITIES AND OTHER SUPPORT OF
NETWORKS ABSOLUTELY BUT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL THAT WAS THIS
LICENSE. FOR THE CLOSURE OF
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS. WORK A
BLOODY. THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION. THE THANK YOU SO
I. SO I DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
CENTER MORE LOCK AND AGAIN I
APPRECIATE- Y. E. YOU'RE DOING
THE BILL AND I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW YOU'RE PRESENTED BEFORE-
AT ASKS THAT WE GET SOME TIME
TO WORK ON IT I KNOW WE HAVE
OUR- THE PUNDITS HERE AND I
THINK THEY DO RAISE SOME.
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES IN TERMS OF
THE BILL BY OCT I DON'T THINK
WE'RE DISAGREEING ON THE
PROBLEM I DON'T THINK WE'RE
DISAGREEING ABOUT- SAYING THAT
SAMPLE PEOPLE IN WE NEED PEOPLE
TO GET HELP. AND BE SAFE PLACES.
I GUESS MY CONCERN ABOUT THE
BILL IS THAT IS THAT. BEFORE US
TODAY AND NOW WE ARE THE POLICY
COMMITTEE IS I WAS HOPING TO IS
GONNA BE A LOT MORE PROGRESS IN
TERMS OF RESOLVING SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED WHEN
THE BILL WAS FIRST PRESENTED.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU
AND THEN ALSO SOME OF THE
OPPOSITON HERE IS THAT. AND I
KNOW THAT SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
AND WE WANT TO DO SOMETHING AND
THAT'S REALLY GOOD I KNOW YOU
WANT TO DO SOMETHING AND YOU'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN MANY OTHER%
VERY IMPORTANT- PAST EFFORTS.
IS THAT- YOU KNOW SINCE WE
FIRST HEARD THE BILL LAST YEAR
TO NOW- KNOWING THAT THEY'RE
STILL GONNA BE SOME TIME FOR
THE REST OF THE YEAR TO TRY TO
WORK OUT. I MEAN WHERE ARE WE
IN TRYING TO RESOLVE SOME OF
THESE ISSUES WE HEARING ABOUT
INCONSISTENCIES AND DEFINITION
AS BLACK OF CLARITY- RESOURCES
IS A LITTLE BIT OF BUDGET THING
SO I'M NOT GONNA SAY THAT WELL
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T TIES SPECIFIC
OF ENOUGH MONEY INTO THE BILL
ITSELF THAT THAT IS SOMETHING
WE CAN WORK OUT THEIR NEST BY
THE WAY THAT'S APPROPRIATIONS
THAT'S NOT US WERE POLICY
COMMITTEE. BUT I DO FEEL THAT
IN TERMS OF THE ACT ITSELF THE
LACK OF CLOTHES ARE DIFFERENT
PETITIONS DEFINITION
INCONSISTENCY I REALIZE THAT
YOU AND I KNOW THIS IS A LITTLE
TENSION HERE THAT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE SO LIKE SAYING WELL
BECAUSE SOME COUNTIES ME
LASTING INTERESTED OR NOT THAT
NOW WE HAVE THIS FIELD COUNTY
CHOICE AND THAT WAS SORT OF.
YOUR WAY TO TRY COMEDY SOME OF
THE ISSUES- OBVIOUSLY NOT THE
SOLUTION I THINK SOME OPPONENTS
LIKE BECAUSE IT CREATES
DISPARITIES BUT I GUESS. WHERE
ARE WE IN TERMS OF
CONVERSATIONS TO TRY TO RESOLVE
THE DIFFERENCES SINCE THE LAST
TIME WE TALKED BECAUSE IN MANY
WAYS I DON'T SEE A LOT OF
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THIS
VERSION WE LAST HEARD AND I'M
JUST CONCERNED THAT. WERE THE
POLICY COMMITTEE WE PASS OUT BY
SAYING WILL PLEASE CONTINUE
WORKING ON IT BUT IF WE DID
THIS FOR THE TIME WE STILL
HAVEN'T MADE THAT MUCH PROGRESS
IN TRYING TO RESOLVE THE
DIFFERENCES. I AM CONCERNED
THAT BURDEN. YEAH WE HAD A LOT
OF TIME TO WORK ON IT THAT WERE
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GETTING THERE LATER AND I DO
FEEL RESPONSIBLE IS THE CHAIR
OF THE POLICY COMMITTEE BE SURE
THAT THE LEAST. WE CAN SEE AN
END IN SIGHT WE ALL KNOW THAT
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARY ALL COME
TOGETHER IN A BILL AND THAT'S
NOT THE STANDARD A HOLD. TO
THIS BILL EITHER THAT WE HAVE
TO GUARANTEE THAT WE HAVE A
SOLUTION- WE HAVE IN FRONT OF
US. BUT YOU KNOW WE ALSO DON'T
WANT IT OPEN ENDED THAT'S WHY
WOULD A POLICY COMMITTEE WILL
BE VOTED OUT WE'RE SENDING A
MESSAGE SAYING THAT YOU KNOW WE
ARE TRYING TO PUSH A CERTAIN
POLICY FORD SO. PERHAPS YOU CAN
SPEAK TO. WHAT HAS PROGRESS
SINCE. YOU INITIALLY PERCENT
THE BILL AND- I'LL- ALSO ASK
THE OPPOSITION TO PERHAPS TALK
ABOUT WHAT THEY SEE IS WHERE DO
WE THINK WE'RE GONNA EVENTUALLY
LAND THIS THING ARE WERE. OUR
WE ARE DO WE HAVE
IRRECONCILABLE DIFFERENCES.
CELLS ARE MARK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THE TWO FOCUSES HAVE
BEEN THE LANGUAGE AND THE
FACILITIES. I'VE BEEN MORE
FOCUSED ON THE FACILITIES. I
THINK THE ISSUE OF LANGUAGE IS
A WEAK ARGUMENT. AND SO I
HAVEN'T FOCUSED ON THAT WE HAVE
FIFTY DIFFERENT STATES WE'VE
BEEN ANALYZED. THEIR DEFINITION
OF GRAVELY DISABLED- I
APOLOGIZE I DIDN'T BRING YOU.
THE SPREADSHEET BUT WE HAD
SOMEONE FROM THE STATE LIBRARY
DO A RATHER THOROUGH REVIEW OF.
WHAT IS- GRAVELY DISABLED AND
THEN HOW IS IT WORKING IN THAT
STATE AND THE BROADER THE
DEFINITION THE LOWER THE
HOMELESSNESS. SO I DIDN'T HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH ARGUING ABOUT.
THE DEFINITION OR ARE ARGUING
ABOUT THE CIVIL RIGHTS ASPECT
BECAUSE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CIVIL RIGHTS. OF ALL
CONSTITUENTS. WE'RE DEALING
WITH A TERM YOU KNOW LEARNING
NEW WORDS HERE IN THE SENATE
BUT TO- IN YOU RIGHT CORRECT ME
BY THE END OF SIDE NAUSEA. I
MEAN SOME PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY HAVE
MENTAL ILLNESS THEY THINK
THEY'RE FINE. AND THAT ISN'T
THE CASE. AND SO I'D. I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT EVERYONE ELSE.
OUT LAST WEEK IN LA WE HAD A
HOMELESS PERSON GO INTO A CAFE.
STAB PATRONS DIED I DON'T KNOW
IF IT WAS MENTAL ILLNESS BUT ON
THE EAST COAST WE HAD A
MENTALLY. ILL PERSONS GET FOR
ANY OF THAT WALKED INTO A
RABBI'S HOUSE WITH A MACHETE
AND STABS FIVE PEOPLE- SO WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE. ADDRESSED AND I
COULD I YOU KNOW I DIDN'T WANT
TO COME HERE WITH THAT LET ME
MISTER CHAIR OF WHAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT BUT I WAS MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE STATE HAS
FAILED. FOR FIFTY YEARS TO
PROVIDE THE COMMUNITY
FACILITIES FOR THOSE THAT WERE
RELEASED FROM. IT'LL HEALTH
INSTITUTIONS I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR MITCHELL FOR
CLARIFICATION- WE'RE CLOSING A
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER WHICH IS
DIFFERENT- AND SO. BUT BUT
FIFTY YEARS AGO WE CLOSED. THE
STATE INSTITUTIONS AND THEY
MIGRATED AND NOW MY CENTRAL
JAIL IS THE BIGGEST MENTAL
HEALTH INSTITUTION IN LA IS THE
SAME AND SO. YOU KNOW WE FELT
WE DIDN'T WHICH WE SAID LET'S
DO LETTERMAN PETROUS IN CLOSE
THE FACILITIES BUT WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO OPEN SOMETHING ELSE
SO THAT'S BEEN THE FOCUS. AND
SO WE HAD NO PLACE LIKE HOME IT
PASSED BUT ALL OF LAST YEAR.
WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR COUNTIES
TO SUBMIT GRANT APPLICATIONS SO
THAT'S BEEN THE PROCESS AND NOW
HOPEFULLY THIS YOUR BILL BE.
APPROVED IN WILL START EITHER
ACQUIRING EXISTING FACILITIES
OR BUILDING SOMETHING I KNOW IN
ORANGE COUNTY- WE HAVE A LAND
TRUST THAT WAS APPROVED-
HOUSING TRUST IT WAS APPROVED
BY THIS LEGISLATURE- BILL
CARRIED BY. THIS ASSUME IN A
DAILY THAT I WAS A CO AUTHOR OF
AND WE'RE TRYING TO. LOCATE
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED SUPPORT OF
HOUSING UNITS IN AND SO THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE IS ALREADY
LOCATED AND STARTED. BREAKING
GROUND ON ONE MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITY IT WILL BE ANNOUNCING
SOON A SECOND AND HOPEFULLY A
THIRD TO WORK WE'RE TRYING TO
DO BUT- AT LEAST IT'S A COUNTY
THAT'S TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
BUT IF WE DON'T GIVE.
PROFESSIONALS THE RIGHT. TOOLS
AND WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF
SPENDING SO MUCH MONEY BUILDING
THINGS IF YOU CAN'T. HOLD
SOMEONE IT ACTUALLY TREAT THEM
UNTIL THEY NORMALIZE BECAUSE
THEN THEY'RE GONNA LOOK AT US
AND SAY WHY DID YOU TAKE SO
LONG. WHY DID YOU TAKE SO LONG
TO TAKE ME UP THE STREETS. OUT
ORANGE COUNTY I'VE BEEN AMAZED
ABOUT HOW PREVALENT. MENTAL
ILLNESS IS I HAVE SOME
WONDERFUL CONSTITUENTS BRIGHT
SMART PEOPLE AND THEY'LL HAVE A
CHILD THAT HAS BIPOLAR OR
DEPRESSION OR SCHIZOPHRENIA. I
HAD A GOOD DOCTOR FRIEND OF
MINE. YEARS AGO SAID TO ME I
SAW MY DAUGHTER FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN TWO YEARS SHE WAS
WALKING ON TUSTIN BOULEVARD.
I'M EXCUSE ME- SHE'S SHE'S
SHE'S SHE'S BETTER NOW YOU KNOW
BUT SHE'S BUT IT BUT IT WHICH
IS ON A ON A MEDICATION PROGRAM
AND YOU'RE GONNA STAY ON THE
PROGRAM- AND IF THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO GET
THESE PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS.
AND TOOK THAT'S BEEN THE FOCUS
MISTER CHAIR IS THAT WE'VE GOT
TO. MOVE FORWARD ON BOTH
INITIATIVES. THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE FACILITIES THE ABILITY
TO HAVE SOME INVOLUNTARY HOLDS
TO HELP NORMALIZE THESE PEOPLE
AND SO THAT'S WHY I FOCUSED ON
THAT. BECAUSE I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT ALL THIS RIGHT TO MEANT
WHEN A CONSTITUENTS AS I DON'T
pBECAUSE THERE'S PEOPLE IN THE
PARKING LOT OR SCARED ME
EITHER. TAKING MY CAR HANDLES
ARE DOING THANK. YOU NOTE. WE
GOT CIVIL RIGHTS FOR EVERYBODY
TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT'S
WHY I MADE THE FOLKS AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE WRONG ANSWER.
LONG LONG ANSWERS GET. A CELL
BUT PERHAPS- I CAN PASS. THE
OPPONENTS CAN ALSO SPEAK TO
WEAR DAY. IT IS. THANK THANK
YOU SIR YES- WINNERS THAT. UP I
WOULD WANT TO POINT OUT THAT.
THIS OF COURSE WAS IS NOT THE
FIRST BILL THAT WE'VE DEALT
WITH IN THE LAST FEW YEARS- ON
THIS VERY ISSUE AND AS YOU KNOW
SENATOR WIENER. HAD HIS
LEGISLATION THAT- ESSENTIALLY
CREATED WITH THE AND- THREE
COUNTIES ONE OF WHICH IS LOS
ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO WHO
IS THE ONLY COUNTY. WHICH IS
THE ONLY COUNTY NOW THAT'S
IMPLEMENTING THAT INTO THAT WAS
I THINK. A PRETTY HARD IGHT.
CRAFTED APPROACH TO TEST WHAT
WAY BE AN ALTERNATIVE TO A
DEFINITION. FOR GRAVELY
DISABLED IN THE CONTEXT OF
THAT. THAT HAS SET UP A PRETTY
STRICTLY- CONFINED- TEST WITH
SO. SIGNIFICANT EVALUATION.
CRITERIA THAT TO AFTER THE
PERIOD OF FIVE YEARS THAT WE
WILL GIVE US. A LOT BETTER
UNDERSTANDING. OF WHAT IT IS TO
JUST YOU KNOW FIDDLE WITH THE
DEFINITION. WHAT WHAT ARE. LIEU
MAJOR CONCERN- THAT WE FOCUS
ON. IS AGAIN AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THE LPS. IS YOUR A- A
WHOLE ARRAY OF. PROCESSES THAT
IS USED TO DETERMINE- WHETHER
AN INDIVIDUAL SHOULD BE HELD
DUE TO A RISK TO THEMSELVES OR
OR OTHERS AND INCLUDED IN THAT
IS REALLY CRAFTING THE RIGHTS
THAT GO ALONG- WITH THAT IT'S
SORT OF PICK OFF ONE PIECE- OF
LPS- WHICH WOULD BE THIS
DEFINITION. SKEWS THE ENTIRE
APPROACH WE WOULD SUGGEST- TO-
HOW HOW WE- MAKE THE
DETERMINATIONS ON WHETHER THE
PERSON HAS A REST OF THEMSELVES
OR OTHERS- CAM IN FINE JUST HAD
ONE OTHER POINT THAT I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I
APPRECIATE SENATOR. MITCHELL
RAISING THIS IS THAT'S REALLY A
FUNDAMENTAL DISTINCTION THAT WE
AS A STATE MADE- BACK WHEN- THE
LAND SHERMAN ACT WAS CREATED%
FOR THE PURPOSES OF PERSONS
WITHOUT DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WE SHOWS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT THOSE WERE MORE
DESERVING. WAS A MORE DESERVING
POPULATION THAN THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
FOR THE THAT POPULATION WE
CREATED AN ENTIRE STRUCTURE
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT ENSURES EVERY INDIVIDUAL
HAS A TREATMENT PLANT HAS
REGIONAL SERVICE DELIVERY. AND
THE AYE AYE IT IS- REMARKABLE
SUCCESS TO ALTERNATELY GET TO
THE POINT THE WE'VE CLOSED THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND MOVED
INDIVIDUALS NOT INTO FACILITIES
BUT IN TO COMMUNITIES. WE NEVER
DID THAT WITH- WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND THAT NEEDS TO BE AND
I THINK PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION. AIR AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NOW HOMELESSNESS
AND ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. AND I
DO HAVE AND THEN WE'LL GET T.
IF YOU DON'T MIND- SO I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT SO WHAT
I'M HEARING FROM YOU CENTER
MORE LIVE IS THAT. HE COULD I
THINK ONE OF THE CONCERNS I
HAVE IS ABOUT THE DEFINITION.
AND I THINK YOU SEE AN ANALYSIS
OF THE INTERPRETATION AND AGAIN
DIFFERENT VARIATIONS AND SO
FORTH AND- IT'S AND I THINK I
HOPE BUT- YOU KNOW- I.
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND. THAT YOU
HAVE SOMEONE WHO MAY. BOTH IT'S
A CHALLENGING TO EVALUATE
SOMEONE TO TELL SOMEONE THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU. NEED
TREATMENT. BUT YOU DON'T WANT
IT BUT I ACTUALLY NO BETTER
THAN YOU SO YOU SHOULD GET IT.
RIGHT AND WE CERTAINLY YEAH WE
CAN ARE YET SAY THAT SOMEONE
WHO IS IN THE THROES OF MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS MAY NOT
NECESSARILY BE IN THE BEST
JUDGMENT TO DECIDE WHAT'S BEST
FOR THEM BUT I THINK THAT'S A
VERY YOU KNOW AT THAT GIVE THE
VERY TRICKY ABOUT HOW YOU KNOW
IT'S VERY TRICKY IF. TO DO THAT
RIGHT TO GO AND SAY SOMEONE. SO.
YOU SO ONE ISSUES FOR ME IS
THAT THIS DEFINITION NOW WHAT
I'M HEARING FROM DISPLAY RIGHTS
IS THAT YOU KNOW WE HAD A
PREVIOUS BILL THE WINNER ANY IS
THERE A PLACE OR IS THERE GOING
TO BE SOMEPLACE WE CAN COME TO
AN AGREEMENT ON A DEFINITION-
THAT THE- CARS THIS SOMEPLACE
WHERE IT'S LIKE OKAY NOW I WANT
REALLY BROAD ONE AND I'D BE ALL
SET TO LIKE WHAT KIND O TESTS
ARE WE GOING TO USE TO BE SURE
THAT WERE APPLYING THIS
DEFINITION APPROPRIATELY AND
ALSO CONSISTENTLY- IS THAT
SOMETHING WHERE WE CAN GET TO
THEM IN THE IN YOUR DISCUSSIONS
IN THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS THE
WELL WHAT WHAT WHERE WHERE IS
THAT GOD IN RELATION TO THIS
DEFINITION BETWEEN LET'S SEE
YOURSELF AND- I THINK DISPLAY
RIGHTS OF AN ORGANIZATION WHOSE
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT. I
CAN KEEP WORKING ON THE
DEFINITION WHO WOULD LIKE ME TO
GO WELL I AM I WELL I THINK SO.
RIGHT I SAID AT THAT. MEETING
WITH THEM. SO I MEAN IS THAT IS
I I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
LIKE IT'S- WHAT I ASSUME YOU'VE
TALKED BEFORE ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE THIS IS BEEN. THAT
DOCTOR TOM INSULT. IN A PRESS
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S APPOINT
POINTY TO THE MIDDLE L. L. A.
U. APPY TO IT OKAY CAN DO
BECAUSE OF THE ISSUE IS I GOT
PEOPLE DYING ON THE STREETS. IT
WELL AND BUT THE THING IS WE
ALSO I MEAN WE NEED TO. I THINK
WE NEED TO TRY TO COME TO A
PLACE WHERE. WHERE BASICALLY
YOU KNOW THE PROBLEM IS THAT
YOU HAVE A DEFINITION THAT
CITIZENS CONSISTENTLY ARE
INAPPROPRIATELY THAT'S GONNA
CAUSE ITS OWN PROBLEMS TOO SO I
MEAN I GET SO WE WE'VE WITH
THAT SO I'M HOPING THAT I WAS
HOPING THAT ACTUALLY WHEN WE
FIRST HEARD THE BILL THAT WE
WOULDACTUALLY BE. MUCH FARTHER
ALONG IN FIGURING OUT LIKE A
AGREED UPON. APPROACH TO THE
POT THIS POPULATION SO I DON'T
KNOW IT WOULD HELP THEIR BEEN-CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN DISPLAY
RIGHTS AND- OFFICE ABOUT THIS.
WEEK WE HAVE NOT HAD ANY
CONVERSATIONS- AND WE'RE A
LITTLE SURPRISED TO SEE THE
ACTUALLY THE AMENDMENT THAT
ACTUALLY WENT THE WRONG
DIRECTION- FOR US BY GIVING THE
COUNTIES OPTIONS ON THIS. I
THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
SENATOR ON THAT AND WHICH I.
TRY TO. ARTICULATE WAS THAT.
THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE THAT GETS
RESOLVED WITH JUST A
DEFINITION. THIS IS A BROADER
ISSUE AS YOU ARE PERFECTLY
AWARE- OF SERVICES OF HOUSING-
AND AVAILABILITY AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED TO THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR PUBLIC GUARDIANS. TO
PROVIDE TO YOU THESE SERVICES
WHICH WE NOW OR ARE. WHOLLY
LACKING- OUT THERE SO TWEAKING
A DEFINITION. THAT JUST BRINGS
MORE PEOPLE INTO A SYSTEM THAT
WE THINK IS ILL EQUIPPED TO
HANDLE THAT- IT IS NOT THE
ANSWER IT NEEDS TO BE A
COMPREHENSIVE DISCUSSION. I
WOULD BE HOPEFUL THAT NOW AS
THE- HAS PUT. HIS IS ALSO A AT
LEAST AS WE'VE READ FOR TODAY
AND SOME OF THIS BROADER
DISCUSSION. THAT THERE IS A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE KIND OF- OF
DISCUSSION RIGHT. GREAT. DIGIT
THERE WAS ALSO AN ADVISER TO
REGIONAL QUESTIONS YEAH SO- I
THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE ON
WHERE WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WERE RELUCTANT TO
SUPPORT ANYTHING AND TELL THE
AUDIT IS RELEASED- WE DON'T A-
DEGREE THAT THIS EXACT
DEFINITION ARE THAT WAY OF
STRUCTURING IT WITH THE COUNTY
OFTEN PROGRAM IS THE WAY TO GO-
WE ALSO SEE AN ANGRY WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT ARE UNDERNEATH A LOT OF
THE RESOURCES- OF THE FACILITY
TYPES AND THAT- THAT NEEDS A
LOT OF WORK. A PUBLIC GUARDIANS
I'M ARE SERIOUSLY UNDERSTAFFED
TODAY IN OUR RECEIVE NO STATE
OR FEDERAL FUNDING- BOARDING
CARES OF THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES WHICH WE PLACE A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVES TEND TO- IS
WHOLLY INADEQUATE- THEY RECEIVE
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS A DAY. TO
PROVIDE FOR ROOM BOARD AND
CARE- THERE'S THE- MEDICAID
BLACKED OUT ON I AM THE
FACILITIES OVER THE SIZE OF
SIXTEEN BADS AND WE DO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY AS THE STATE- TO
APPLY FOR A FEDERAL I AM THE
WAY FOR THIS YEAR AND WE DO
APPRECIATE CENTER MAROC SUPPORT
ON THAT. AND SO COUNTIES WE ARE
VERY INTERESTED IN THAT BUT
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
UNDERNEATH THE LAW THAT ARE
REALLY BUT- BENEFICIAL TO THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM I HAVE- OUR-
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE DO SEE THAT
ARE ON COMMUNITY BASED- FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS UNDER THE
IMAGE ASIDE TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF CONSERVATORSHIP
BETTER UTILIZED IN- ACROSS THE
STATE WE HAVE COUNTY IS THAT-
OVERSPEND ON. VERSUS OTHERS ON
IT THEIR FSP PROGRAMS AND THEY
ACTUALLY DO SEE A REDUCTION IN
THE UTILIZATION OF
CONSERVATORSHIP BUT THEM AT THE
SAME POINT WE GETTING BY THE
STATE BY- OVERSPENDING ON MASS
STP PROGRAMS FIRST FATHER'S SO
THERE'S- THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPOUND. THINGS IT'S A VERY
COMPLEX SYSTEM THAT IS
OCCURRING AND THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPLEXITY THAT WE DON'T SEE A
SIMPLE DEFINITION CHANGE WOULD
SOLVE THE ISSUES THAT WE SEE-
OUT OF SOCIETY LEVEL. SOME BUT
WE ARE HAPPY TO AND DINNER
CONVERSATIONS OKAY. ALRIGHT YES
SAYS EARLY BY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IT THIS IS JUST I THINK
SOMETHING THAT PLAGUES ALL OF
US AND IT IS SOMETHING THAT NOT
ONE BILL IS GOING TO FIX AND I
AGREE THAT IT'S A SOCIETAL
ISSUE- WHEN PEOPLE SAY I THINK
SENATOR MITCHELL WHEN YOU WENT
TO UTAH AND- AND DID THAT TO
SEE WHAT HOW THE HEAD OF THEIR
HOMELESSNESS. AND THEY HAVE A
3% HOMELESSNESS I THINK IT'S
DIFFERENT BECAUSE I THINK WHAT
YOU BROUGHT BACK TO US IS THAT
PEOPLE IN UTAH LOOK AT SOMEONE
WHO'S ON THE STREET AS THEIR
BROTHER OR THEIR SISTER AND WE
DON'T DO THAT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD SAY IN
MANY OTHER AREAS IN THIS
COUNTRY SO HOW DO WE CHANGE
PEOPLE'S PERSPECTIVE I KNOW
WHEN I LOOK AT SOMEONE ON THE
STREET I THINK BY THE GRACE OF
GOD IT'S NOT ME OR MY FAMILY-
AND MENTAL ILLNESS IS A HUGE
ISSUE AND YOU'RE RIGHT WE
FAILED MANY MANY YEARS AGO. AS
A STATE- I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
YOU KEEP WORKING ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU THINK THAT
LANGUAGE IS A WEAK ARGUMENT BUT
I HAVE TO DISAGREE I THINK THAT
WORDS MATTER AND IF WE DON'T
GET THE WORDING RIGHT WE COULD
ACTUALLY BE IN A WORSE
SITUATION THAN WERE IN- I'LL
GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE OF
WORRYING THAT DIDN'T GET US
WHERE WE WANTED TO BE. A NUMBER
OF YEARS AGO- RATE IT'S A IT
WAS THE LANGUAGE WAS THEY
SHOULD BE TESTED AND WE ENDED
UP BEING IN A SITUATION OR RAPE
KITS OF SET ON- SHELVES FOR
YEARS AND THERE'S A HUGE
BACKLOG THERE'S A NEW LAW NOW
THAT SAYS RAPE KITS SHALL BE
TESTED SO THAT WILL ELIMINATE
ANY FUTURE CLUB BUT I THINK
WORDS ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
SO I WOULD LOVE TO SEE YOU KEEP
WORKING THE BILL. I ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THIS THREE AND WHAT
THEY COME UP WITH BEFORE WE
START MAKING DECISIONS. AND WE
DON'T HAVE ALL THE FACTS. YOUR
WORK ON IT I JUST KEEP. ON THE
BILL DOES NOT GET OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY. YOU KEEP
WORKING ON IT AND I ALSO HIGHLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO TALK TO
OPPOSITION. BECAUSE I KNOW WHEN
I HAVE BILLS AND THERE'S
OPPOSITION I ALWAYS MEET WITH
THEM BECAUSE SOMETIMES ACTION
GOOD IDEAS. SO I THINK YOU FOR
BEING SO CONCERNED THOUGH AND I
AM JUST SORRY CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. OKAY ANY. OKAY SO
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED SIR MORE
LIKE I. NOW I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING O THIS ISSUE FOR A
LONG TIME I WAS HOPEFUL THAT BY
THE TIME WE GOT HERE TODAY THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN MORE PROGRESS.
HI I AM CONCERNED FOR EXAMPLE
THAT THAT THE DEFINITION ISSUE
I MEAN IT'S NOT JUST WORDS THIS
IS. A PROPOSED LAW IT'S A BILL
WAS GONE IT WOULD BE LAWS IT
PASSES THROUGH AND- AND- A PRE
SHEET THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DRESS AND UNDRESS AN ISSUE THAT
WEALL NEED TO ADDRESS SO HOW
DO WE SURE WE HELP PEOPLE WHO
NEED HELP. RIGHT WHO MAY BE ON
THE STREETS AND SO FORTH SO I
SHARE THAT WITH YOU AND I WANT
TO TRY TO COME OF THE SOLUTION.
MY CONCERN IS IT THIS TIME IS
THAT- IT THAT WILL YOU KNOW AT
THE END AND KNOW IT TOO. TO BE
FAIR TO CENTER MORE LACK I MEAN
I WANT TO SAY TO. THE OPPONENTS
IS THAT BECAUSE AFTER I DO ALSO
CHAIR THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
I THINK IT'S A BIT MUCH TO
EXPECT. CENTER MORE LIKE TO
WRITE A BILL TO ENCOMPASS ALL
THE THINGS THAT BEEN BROUGHT UP
ABOUT THE WHOLE SYSTEM OKAY.
RIGHT SO I THINK THAT THAT YOU
KNOW I IT'S NOW I THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IN SOME
WAY BUT IT. DOES NOT CAN BE THE
SOLUTION TO EVERY SINGLE PIECE
WE OFFER AND BILLS AND WE KNOW
THAT IS THERE A CELL THAT I
THINK A BIT IN A BIT OF A
BURDEN- OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE
DOUBLE THE POLICY COMMITTEE SO
SOME OF THIS WOULD ACTUALLY BE
APPROPRIATIONS HOW MUCH WOULD
IT COST ETCETERA I MEAN DOESN'T
NEED TO TOUCH ON THAT AND I
THINK THAT IT'S A BIT MISSING
SO I APPRECIATE YOU SAID YOU
CAN LOOK AT THE SILLY SIDE BUT
ALSO. THIS THE SIDE ABOUT IT
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE A
CATEGORY IN THE PEOPLE IN THAT
CATEGORY WOULD PEOPLE GO INTO
THAT CATEGORY- BASICALLY WE'RE
GONNA SAY GOVERNMENT HAS
CERTAIN POWERS OVER YOU.
ADDITIONAL POWERS OVER YOU
RIGHT AND- I DEBTS OSTENSIBLY
FOR YOUR QUOTE YOUR OWN GOOD I
GUESS I GUESS THAT'S WHAT- THIS
IS A- DEBTS. NOW THAT'S THE
RATIONALE BE THE POLICY
RATIONALE OR THE REASON- AND-
AND THEN SECONDARILY IN YOU
POINTED OUT YOU KNOW BABY IT'S
ALSO FOR THE PROTECTION OF THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL- THAT AGAIN I
WILL BE CAREFUL WE DON'T
STIGMATIZE PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH AS- NECESSARY BE MORE
DANGEROUS THAN OTHER PEOPLE.
BUT SIDES ONE BE CAREFUL ABOUT
THAT TOO BUT WE BUT BEFORE BUT
WE'RE GOING TO BE A CATEGORY
THAT NEEDS TO BE. WELL DEFINED
BECAUSE OTHERWISE THEN IT GOES
THE COURTS COURTS A DIFFERENT
RULINGS DIFFERENT
ADMINISTRATORS OUR BUREAUCRATS
ARE MAKING DIFFERENT
DEFINITIONS DIFFERENT BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. AND THEN WE'LL
HAVE THIS WHOLE HODGE PODGE
AND- WE SHOULD ACTUALLY LOOKED
AT ALL THE DIFFERENT STATES AND
LOOKED AT ALL THESE DIFFERENT
DEFINITIONS AND DID THAT KIND
OF BACKGROUND WORK. BUT I HOPE
THAT ACTUALLY THAT THEN DOING
THAT- KNEW THAT. I THINK IT
SHOWS THE CHALLENGE OF SAYING
WELL WE NEED TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING FOR CALIFORNIA THAT'S
MORE WELL DEFINED THAT. COURTS
AND MINISTRY EDITORS AND BOARDS
COUNTIES AND EVEN THE STATE
ITSELF. CAN BE MORE CAN CAN CAN
CAN BE SURE THAT WERE DOING THE
RIGHT THING AND THAT WERE. WERE
WERE DOING THIS CONSISTENTLY
BECAUSE- IT THE ANSWER ISN'T
GOING TO. MEAN VARIATIONS IN
REGIONS BUT IT'S NOT LIKE WELL
IF YOU. HAPPEN TO BE IN THIS
COUNTY YOUR TREE THIS WAY
THAT'S THE RIGHT WAY AND THAT
CAN. ON THE ELKS SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT OKAY. SO
UNFORTUNATELY I AM NOT ABLE TO
SUPPORT. THE BILL TODAY IN THIS
FORM BECAUSE OF THAT- AND- A
YOU KNOW I IT BUT I DO. HOPE
THAT WE CAN WORK CONTINUE TO
WORK I KNOW THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO KEEP WORKING ON IT- AT ONE
TO HELP YOU- IF WE CAN FIND A
WAY TO ADDRESS. THAT ISSUE IN A
FUTURE PIECE OF LEGISLATION I
DO THINK IT'S TOO FAR AWAY FROM
WHERE OF HOPING IT WOULD BE- I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO TALK NOT ONLY
OF COURSE WITH DR INSEL OVER
THE MINISTRATION BUT ALSO AT
THIS OF THE RACE AND ONE. WE
ALL DONE BILLS WE MAY NOT GET
THE OPPOSITION MAY NOT KNOW SO
YOU'D BE ALL ON BOARD AT LEAST
WE'VE TRIED TO ADDRESS. THE
IMPORTANT ISSUES AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S- I
DON'T FEEL LIKE THERE'S BEEN
ENOUGH PROGRESS MADE FOR ME TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY- SO WITH THAT- WHICH
ELECT CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I THANK YOU FOR RELEASED
ALLOWING ME TO USE A LITTLE
LEVITY AS- POOR AS IT WAS
BECAUSE THIS IS AN EXTREMELY.
SERIOUS SERIOUS SUBJECT AND-
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE.
CONSTITUENTS IN YOUR OFFICE
AND- THEY INFORMED ME THAT THEY
LOST THEIR SON. NO IT'S- YOU
KNOW AND IT'S JUST SOMETHING
YOU WANT TO WORK ON SO.
RESEARCHER WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE WORKING. THE
LETTERMAN PATRICK SHORT ACT YOU
KNOW TO SAY THAT IT'S
SUCCESSFUL. I WOULD JUST SAY GO
OUTSIDE. GO TO SKID ROW IN LA.
LOOK AT THE DATA IT'S NOT
WORKING. WE A HAVE PEOPLE I'VE
I'VE TOURED SOME INCREDIBLE STE
ON THE SHELTERS- SAN ANTONIO'S
HAVEN FOR HOPE. AND EVEN THERE
THEY HAD TO SET UP A COURTYARD
SO PEOPLE TO PUT UP THEIR TENTS
THEY REFUSE TO GO INTO THE
BUILDINGS AND SAID. NOT SLEEP
IN THE COT. JUST HAD STEP TO
OUR FACILITY IN THE YOLO CENTER
AREA JUST LAST WEEK. SAME
THING. YOU KNOW. MOST OF THE
DAY ANT TO STAY IN THE
BUILDINGS THERE. SO WE HAVE
PEOPLE THAT WE NEED TO HELP AND
YOU'VE- YOU'VE SEEN CAL MATTERS
TO A RATHER EXHAUSTIVE. SERIES
OF ARTICLES ON MENTAL HEALTH
AND WHERE WE SHOULD BE GOING
IN. I THINK THIS. THIS FALLS
INTO WHERE WE SHOULD BE GOING I
THINK THE DEFINITION IS FINE SO
I APOLOGIZE FOR. QUESTION ABOUT
IT I JUST. AYE AYE AYE. AYE
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE. I THINK
THE DEFINITION IS FINE WE
WORKED ON IT AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT IS OPTIONAL. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS OPTIONAL JUST
LIKE LAWRENCE Là IS OPTIONAL.
AND SO WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR-
PEOPLE STILL HAVE PSYCHOTIC.
EPISODES AND A SEVENTY TWO HOUR
HOLD ISN'T GONNA CUT IT. IN
YOUR POSITION SO YOU KNOW WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT YOU KNOW OUR
EMERGENCY ROOMS CAN HANDLE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SPACE TO HOLD
THEM FOR THREE OR FOUR FIVE
DAYS SO. WE'VE GOT TO WORK IN
CANADA DO EVERYTHING BECAUSE
THIS AUDIT YEAH WHICH I SUPPORT.
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
RESULTS BUT IT'S AN APRIL.
MINUTES PAST THE DEADLINE TO DO
SOMETHING. FOR THIS YEAR AND
WE'VE GOT TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER FOR. THIS PRIVATE YOU
KNOW THIS THIS ISSUE FOR THE
PARENTS. ARE THESE PARENTS
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR KIDS ARE
OVER EIGHTEEN THEY CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ANYMORE EVEN HIP
ALLISER PREVENTING THEM TO A
FROM FINDING WHAT THE DIAGNOSIS
IS THE EVEN HELP THEIR KIDS.
AND THEY CAN'T FILE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ORDERS THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT THE SHERIFF BECAUSE AND
THEY CAN'T TALK TO THEIR CHILD
FOR TWO YEARS I MEAN IT'S JUST
EVERYTHING IS. WHACKED AND YES
I CAN'T DO A BILL THAT FIXES
EVERYTHING. IN ONE SHOT BUT IF.
HELPING PEOPLE WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS. GETTING BE A
PROPER TREATMENT GETTING THEM
OFF THE STREETS. I THINK THAT'S
THE MAIN THING TO DO AND THAT'S
WHY I THINK THIS BILL IS WORTH
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR GROVE- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL PAN. WHAT. YES
IT'S BEEN DENTAL REFERRED TO
JUDICIARY. SO I CAN. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ NO GROVE GROVE I HER
TADO HER TADO I LEYVA LEYVA NO
MITCHELL. MONNING RUBIO. TO SO
THE VOTESCURRENTLY TO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIRMAN RANKING FIGURE
LEADERSHIP AND ALLOWING ME TO
WORK ON THIS BILL EVENTUALLY
WELL I HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE I I'LL BE
HERE. THANK YOU YOU I THANK YOU.
RIGHT THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB SEVEN THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN I
BELIEVE I SEEN WHAT THE NEW
PATIENTLY WAITING. SO THAT'S
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA SUMMER PRIVACY ACT
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS HE SEVEN THIRTEEN WOULD
FURTHER HARMONIZE THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT WITH EXISTING
CONFIDENTIALITY AND PRIVACY
RULES FOR CERTAIN HEALTH
RELATED INFORMATION WHILE THE
CCPA WENT INTO EFFECT ON
JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR IT
WILL HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ON HEALTH CARE
OPERATIONS MEDICAL RESEARCH AND
FTA PRODUCT AND PATIENT SAFETY.
AB SEVEN THIRTEEN WILL MITIGATE
THE HARM THAT THESE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THE C. C. P. A.
WILL HAVE ON HEALTH RELATED
INFORMATION AND ULTIMATELY
SAFEGUARD LIFESAVING HEALTH
CARE RESEARCH TO BETTER LIVES
TO BETTER THE LIVES OF PATIENTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THIS BILL
WOULD MAKE FOR MAIN
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE CCPA
RELATED TO THE FOLLOWING AREAS
THE DE IDENTIFICATION STANDARD
FOR HEALTH INFORMATION HUMAN
SUBJECTS RESEARCH SEPARATE FROM
CLINICAL TRIALS. BUSINESS
ASSOCIATES THAT HANDLE HEALTH
INFORMATION SUBJECTED TO HELP
OUT AND FTA PRODUCT AND PATIENT
SAFETY AB SEVEN THIRTEEN ONLY
EXAMS HEALTH INFORMATION THAT
IS ALREADY SUBJECTED TO FEDERAL
REGULATIONS I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR HIS CONSIDERATION OF
THIS MEASURE AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
THOROUGH ANALYSIS THE SUGGESTED
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT PRESENTED
IN COMMENT ELEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS IS SOMETHING I AM
COMMITTED TO WORK ON- AND THE
BILL'S NEXT POLICY- COMMITTEE
WHICH- WE BELIEVE WILL BE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WITH ME
TODAY IS STUCK PARA CORD. WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CLINICAL
RESEARCH ORGANIZATIONS AND
FIELDING GRIEVES WITH THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION TO TESTIFY. THANK
YOU BUT THIS IS SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN PAN MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE UNTUK PARA
CORD. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ACT
CROAK HE ASSOCIATION OF
CLINICAL RESEARCH ORGANIZATIONS
WHICH REPRESENTS THE WORLD'S
LEADING CLINICAL RESEARCH AND
TECHNOLOGY ORGANIZATIONS. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN THIRTEEN
HEALTH CARE AMENDMENTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT.
WITH MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
ENGAGED IN RESEARCH ACTIVITIES
IN EVERY U. S. STATE. AND A
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ACT PRO
MEMBERS MANAGED OR OTHERWISE
SUPPORTED HE MAJORITY OF ALL
FDA REGULATED CLINICAL TRIALS
WORLDWIDE. BESIDES CLINICAL
TRIALS WHICH ANSWER THE
BASELINE QUESTIONS OF WHETHER A
NEW DRUG IS SAFE AND EFFECTIVE.
SACRAMENTO VERSION REGULARLY
USE HEALTH INFORMATION FOR A
WIDE RANGE OF NON
INTERVENTIONAL RESEARCH
INCLUDING SAFETY SURVEILLANCE
AND EPIDEMIOLOGY STUDIES
PATIENT REGISTRY AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES ANALYSES AND
COMPARATIVE EFFECTIVENESS
RESEARCH. THESE STUDIES DANCER
EQUALLY IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
LIKE- RESPONSE TO A NEW DRUG
AND WHO DOES NOT WHAT SIDE
EFFECTS OCCUR IN WHAT KINDS OF
PEOPLE IS A NEW PRODUCT MORE OR
LESS EFFECTIVE THAN OLDER ONE.
QUESTIONS THAT HELPED LEAD US
TOWARD TAILORING THE RIGHT
TREATMENT FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
PERSONALIZED MEDICINE.
SACROILIAC THAT THE AMENDMENTS
BEFORE YOU WILL REFINE AND
IMPROVE THE CCPA AND BETTER
HARMONIZE THE STATUTE WITH
FEDERAL AND INTERNATIONAL
HEALTH RESEARCH ETHICS AND
PRIVACY REGULATIONS. REMOVAL OF
THESE TECHNICAL BUT IMPORTANT
AMENDMENTS WILL ENSURE THAT
CRUCIAL HEALTH RESEARCH THE
DRIVES IMPROVEMENTS IN MEDICAL
CARE AND THE HEALTH OF
INDIVIDUALS AND POPULATIONS
WILL NOT BE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
HAS THE CCPA TAKES EFFECT. AND
WILL BENEFIT HEALTH CARE AND
RESEARCH ORGANIZATIONS AND
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS ALIKE AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY I'LL
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
SUPPORT I DON'T THINK WE
RECEIVED ANY FORMAL OPPOSITION
OF QUICK. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
FEEL AGREED TO THE VANCE
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION-
JUST LITTLE BRIEF THING ABOUT
POLICY PROCESS HERE- AB I KNOW
WE GOT STARTED LOOKING AT CPA
LAST YEAR FRANKLY THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED ISSUE FOR
US AS WERE ALREADY HEAVILY
REGULATED THERE IS SORT OF
MULTIPLE OVERLAPPING- CIRCLES
WITHIN A VENN DIAGRAM OF
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT.
AND OF COURSE THERE'S NO
INSTRUCTION MANUAL FOR THIS
ISSUE IS VERY VERY COMPLICATED-
SO AGAIN I THINK THIS BILL IS.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR LIFE
SCIENCE AND LIFE SAVING
RESEARCH- IS VERY VERY
DELIBERATELY DRAFTED TO AVOID
ABUSE BY- CERTAIN ON HEALTH
CARE ENTITIES- AND SO WE REALLY
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
HEARING TODAY- IT'S REALLY
URGENT IMPORTANT FRANKLY TO
START THE CONVERSATION SAID A
POLICY MARKER FOR OTHER STATES-
HUGE FIXED TO SOME OF OUR
MULLIN FOR BRING THE BILL
TODAY. REALLY WE SHOULD THE
VALUABLE INPUT OF THE PRIVACY.
ADVOCATES IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE STAFF AND PRIVACY
COMMITTEES STAFF THAT WERE WERE
WORKING WITH- FOR THE NEXT NEXT
COMMITTEE- AND FINALLY I WANT
TO GIVE A- SHOUT OUT TO IN A
THANKS TO MISTER ALLISON TAGGER
IN CENTER HERTZBERG FOR. THEIR
WORK TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES. ON THE INITIATIVE- SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY THANKS
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BACK MICROPHONE NAME
ORGANIZATIONS ADDITION MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MARIN HIGGINS
REPRESENTING BY A CALM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS HAPPY NEW YEAR
ALL OF ROCK RAY CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. HELLO TEN WATER WITH
WILDER LAW OFFICES I. ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE
IT'S URGENTLY NEEDED TO PROTECT
MEDICAL RESEARCH THANK. YOU.
FRED NO WERE REPRESENTING FORMA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MR TURN MEMBERS MARIA SPUR
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
YOU. HIGHLAND LEGAL RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF BIO IN SUPPORT YOU.
MR MEMBERS JOHN DORY ON BEHALF
OF UNITED HEALTH GROUP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SAMANTHA CORBIN
ON BEHALF OF THE PRIVACY
COALITION WHICH INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF MY CLIENTS ARE COMMON
SENSE KIDS ACTION ACLU
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE
AND OTHERS WE ACTUALLY HAVE NO
POSITION ON THIS MEASURE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN
THE ADVOCATES GOING ALL THE WAY
BACK TO THE PASSAGE OF CCPA AS
PART OF A GOOD FAITH COMMIT
WITH WITH THEM TO DEAL WITH
THESE ISSUES WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO AS IT MOVES THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. OKAY ALL
RIGHT AYE SIR SO IT IS ALWAYS
MOVED HER HAND FIRST THOUGH SO
GIVE HER THE SECOND YEAR ALL
RIGHT- SO. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR PRESENTING THE BILL
SOMETHING FOR HIM SOMETHING WE
NEED TO DO TO JUROR FOR LIFE
SCIENCES WHICH LIKE CLOTHES.
SIMPLY UP PASTURE AYE VOTE AND-
COMMITTED TO WORKING ANY
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL ISSUES- I
KNOW THERE ARE SOME REMAINING I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK THOSE
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO THE
MOTION ACTUALLY SIT DO PASS RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON RULES
FOR TO THEN THE SIDE. I THINK I
WON'T PRESUME FOR THEM WHAT
THEIR AGAIN THE SIDE BUT IT'S
PRIDE JUDICIARY- AND IT'S BEEN
SECONDED BY CENTER IS ALWAYS
SECRETIVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PAN HI CAN I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I GROW. GROW I HER TADO HER
TADO AYE LEYVA MITCHELL.
MONNING MONNING I RUBIO. OKAY
SISKIYOU HAVE FIVE VOTES SO YOU
HAVE ENOUGH VOTES TO PASS
THROUGH THE HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU. SO MUCH. OKAY THIRD ROW.
THE GAVEL TO YOU. SO FOR
PRESENTATION OF ITEM NUMBER ONE
S. BEFORE SIX. AND CAN. THE
RIGHT. OKAY DOCTOR PAN SB FOUR
OH SIX. YES THANK YOU THE
SERVER GROVE- MEMBERS SP FOUR
SIX IS A REWRITE OF AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE OF TWENTY TEN
THE TWENTY TEN LEGISLATION PUT
INTO TO CALIFORNIA LAW THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT THAT HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS PROVIDE COVERAGE
PREVENTIVE HEALTH SERVICES
WITHOUT COST SHARING. AS
BEFORE- SIX RE WRITES THE LAW
TO REMOVE THE FEDERAL CITATIONS
AND INSTEAD PUT THE ACTUAL
FEDERAL LAW PROVISIONS INTO
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH EFFORTS TO
UNDO SOME OR ALL OF THE ACA IT
IS PRUDENT AT THIS TIME TO
INSURE TO CALIFORNIA'S WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE IMPORTANT PREVENTIVE
SERVICES WITHOUT COST SHARING.
AND WITH THAT ASPECT WE ASK FOR
AN AYE THOSE GIVE. THIS IS IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DIANA DOUGLAS ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA THE
STATE WIDE HEALTH CARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION WE ARE
PLEASED TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR OH SIX WHICH WILL
CODIFY INTO CALIFORNIA LAW
PROVISIONS OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT THAT OUTLAW COPAYS AND
OTHER COST SHARING FOR
PREVENTIVE SERVICES. PREVENTIVE
SERVICES ARE ONE OF OUR SEATS
TOP PUBLIC HEALTH PRIORITIES
ACCESS TO THESE SERVICES ALLOWS
US TO IDENTIFY SERIOUS
CONDITIONS EARLY OR PERHAPS
AVOID THEM ALTOGETHER THESE
SERVICES INCLUDE A RANGE OF
CARE INCLUDING CANCER AN STD
SCREENINGS PREGNANCY RELATED
CARE AND SUPPORT WELL CHILD
VISITS AND IMMUNIZATIONS
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN EVEN NOMINAL
COST SHARING CAN DISCOURAGE THE
USE OF THESE SERVICES THESE
EFFECTS ARE PARTICULARLY
PRONOUNCED AMONG LOW INCOME
PEOPLE BUT CAN ALSO BE SEEN
AMONG MIDDLE AND THE HIGHER
INCOME CONSUMERS AS WELL. WELL
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG REQUIRED
SURE IS AN PLANS TO COVER MOST
PREVENTIVE CARE. THAT
AFFORDABLE CHARACTER IN A STEP
FURTHER BY PROHIBITING COST
SHARING FOR THESE SERVICES.
WE'VE ALREADY CODE CODIFIED
MOST OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
PROVISIONS INTO STATE LAW IN
ORDER TO ENSURE WERE PROTECTED.
FROM FUTURE ATTACKS ON THE PART
OF THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
OR COURTS. HOWEVER THIS IS ONE
OF SEVERAL PROVISIONS REMAINING
THAT ARE TIED TO OUR FEDERAL
STATUTE. AS BEFORE- SIX ONE
SURE CALIFORNIANS ARE ABLE TO
CONTINUE ACCESSING PREVENTIVE
CARE FREE OF BURDENSOME COPAYS
AND COST SHARING. WITH THAT WE
WOULD SUPPORT AS BEFORE- SEX
FOR A SIX AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHER MEMBERS AND
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
FLOOR ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT GETTING OUR
LETTER AND OR IN SUPPORT AS
WELL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS NICK LOUISE US ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS. WE
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THIS MEASURE AS OF YET-
CONSIDERING ALL THE CHANGES IN
THE HEALTH CARE ENVIRONMENT
SINCE THE INITIAL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IN
CALIFORNIA WE THINK THIS IS A
LOGICAL. DISCUSSION TO BE
HAVING. SOME OF OUR PLAN
EXPERTS HAVE IDENTIFIED. YOU
KNOW SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH
THE LANGUAGE. IN ADDITION TO
THAT THERE ARE FEDERAL RULES
AND REGULATIONS THAT ARE IN
PLACE AT A REFERENCE IN THE
CURRENT STATE LAW. AND WE MIGHT
WANT TO TAKE. A LOOK AT THOSE-
BEFORE WE WOMEN EIGHT THAT
LANGUAGE- THAT CROSS REFERENCE
AND STATE LAW TO THOSE RULES
AND REGULATIONS BECAUSE SOME OF
THOSE COULD BE HELPFUL.
POTENTIALLY SO WE JUST ASK
RESPECTFULLY THAT THE LINES OF
COMMUNICATION REMAIN OPEN
BETWEEN US AND THE AUTHOR- IT
HAS AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION. SEEN ANSWER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SOURCE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL
CERTAINLY WILL BE WORKING WITH
THE HEALTH PLANS- TO LOOK AT
THE LANGUAGE TO SEE IF THERE'S-
IF THERE'S ADJUSTMENTS WE NEED
TO MAKE TO ADDRESS- ANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT- THEY PHRASE BUT I
THINK FUNDAMENTALLY AGAIN- THIS
IS ABOUT ENSURING THAT PEOPLE-
GET TO PREVENTIVE CARE AND THAT
WE DON'T CREATE UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS TO THAT SO WAS THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I PUT. IN
YOU KNOW I DO APOLOGIZE I
DIDN'T BRING BACK THE DICE FOR
QUESTIONS SO IS THERE QUESTIONS
I APOLOGIZE NO QUESTIONS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CALL THANK YOU
MISTER TAUGHT OF ISABEL. AND
THANK YOU FOR CLOSE SENATOR PAN.
SO IT'S TO PASS AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THE PROVISIONS COMMITTEE.
KOREAN OF THE ROLE SORRY. PAN I
AM AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D
GROW I WROTE I HER TONTO TONTO
AYE LEYVA MITCHELL MONNING
MORNING I RUBIO. IF. ZERO FIVE
THAT SIR THANK YOU. AND IN THAT
SENSE OF. AND JUSTICE CENTER
NINETY CENTER GROVE ON NEXT
FINALLY WE DO HAVE A CONSENT
ITEM- WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR
ACR ONE A ONE- ON PEDIATRIC
CANCER BY SIMILAR LACKEY IT'S
THE ONLY ITEM ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUR MOTION FOR THE
SENATE CALENDAR AND MOVED IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER GROE- AND
SO- THE SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CAN. I A GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
GROW GROUP I HER TADO HER TITLE
AYE LEYVA MITCHELL MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO. FIVE K. THAT
CAN TAKE HOURS FIVE VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OF AN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. OKAY LET'S GO BACK
THROUGH SETTING OF. ONE ANOTHER
ONE. OKAY OKAY CENTER MONEY I
BELIEVE SO WE'RE GONNA RE OPEN
THE ROLE ON ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
SIX FORTY BY CENTER MORE LOCK-
CIGARETTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS CAN. MITCHELL
MONNING. RUBIO. RIGHT SO THAT
OF. OKAY SO THE VOTE CURRENTLY
IS TO AND WE'LL CALL COULD YOU
TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE TRAVEL.
OKAY LOOKS SINCE THE RITUALS
HERE LET'S RE OPEN THE ROLE-
AND- I NUMBER THREE SB SEVEN
THIRTEEN BY SUMMER MULLIN US
SIX THREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS. LEYVA
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE RUBIO.
OKAY SO THAT'S CURRENTLY SIX
ZERO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS SHOULD VOTE ON.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA REWRITE ADULT
IN THE ROLE OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IT'S ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB ONE NO AC ARE ONE OH ONE AT
SIX THREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS LEYVA
MITCHELL. MITCHELL AYE RUBIO
AYE RUBIO AYE SEVEN OKAY SO
THAT IS CURRENTLY AT SEVEN ZERO
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. OKAY SALUTE WILL GO
FROM THE TOP AGAIN- SO ITEM
NUMBER ONE AS BEFORE AS SIX BY
PAN- SICKLY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS LEYVA
MITCHELL. MITCHELL AYE RUBIO
AYE RUBIO BY THE AT SEVEN OKAY
SO THAT SO CURRENTLY SEVEN
ZERO- NEXT IS SB SIX FORTY BY
CENTER MORE LAX SECURITIES CALL
THE ROLL THAT'S MEMBERS HAN.
MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO. OKAY I
MISSED HIS ACTION. YEAH. OKAY
SO- THAT BILL- THE VOTES
CURRENT IS TO SO THAT BILL
FAILS- ACTUALLY WELL THERE'S NO
RECONSIDERATION RIGHT OKAY SO
IF- SO AS THE SIX FORTY AT TO
FILLS PASSAGE. O'DONNELL OKAY-
IT WITHOUT OBJECTION- WE WILL
GRANT RECONSIDERATION OKAY.
TIGHT SO THE AND THEN- NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTEEN BY A
SUMMARY MULLIN SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
LEYVA RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE. THAT
BILLS CURRENTLY SEVEN ZERO IN
ADDITION TO EVERYTHING ELSE
RIGHT WOMEN RIGHT. I THINK IT'S
OKAY OKAY SO WHICH THE LEYVA SO
LEYVA IS CHAIRING THIS IS
EDUCATION. BILLS SHE'S ON HER
WAY OKAY THAT'S GOOD
. OKAY
WE'RE GOING TO REOPEN THE ROLE
ONE ITEM NUMBER ONE SP FOUR A
SIX TO THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS LEYVA
LEYVA HI. THAT BILL WAS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER THREE THREE ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTEEN BY
SUMMER MULLIN SECURITIES CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS LEYVA.
LEYVA I THINK THAT BILLS OUT
EIGHT ZERO FINALLY WE HAVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- AT THE WILL
OF ONE ITEM ACR ONE A ONE BY
CENTER ABOUT A SIMILAR LACKEY
SORT OF THESE ALL THE ROLE
THAT'S MEMBERS LEYVA. LEYVA
HIGH EIGHT OKAY CONSENT
CALENDARS APPROVED EIGHT ZERO
WHAT THAT WE'VE INCLUDE THE
AGENDA OF THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WE
ARE NOW THE CHURN